bonjour merci de nous rejoindre ce matin
sur l'antenne de public sénat nous vous
proposons ce matin et bien de revoir une
séance qui s'est déroulée hier après
midi au sénat il s'agit de la
proposition de loi ou autour des taxis
et des vtc vous le savez le vote du
sénat était très attendu puisqu'il y
avait beaucoup de différends entre les
taxis et les vtc qu'il y avait eu des
amendements et notamment un amendement
du député thomas thévenoud adopté par
l'assemblée nationale qui avait mis en
émoi le monde des vtc puisque cet
amendement obliger les véhicules privés
avec chauffeur à revenir à leur base de
départ entre deux courses hier soir au
sénat et bien une position de repli a
été trouvé une position plus consensuel
puisque désormais les vtc et bien ne
seront plus obligés de revenir leur base
s'ils peuvent et bien prétendre à avoir
une autre course déjà engagés donc je
vous propose de revoir ce matin sont de
30 années bien toute la discussion qui a
eu lieu hier après midi autour de cette
proposition loi taxi vtc très bonne
séance à tous dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à mme
charles revers pour le groupe hey ump
madame la présidente
même le ministre le rapporteur
chers collègues je tout d'abord
féliciter notre reportage fillol même et
et les services de la commission même si
vous allez voir que j'ai beaucoup de
réserve mais ils ont dû travailler dans
un temps extrêmement contraint pour nous
présenter le rapport et je crois qu'il
faut souligner
si on peut prédire sans risque
l'adoption ou le rejet de cette
proposition de loi ne fera pas un
tournant de la nature il n'en demeure
pas moins que ce texte à une très forte
valeur symbolique à mes yeux nous savons
tous ces difficultés qu'ils éprouvent
notre économie depuis 2008 et plus
encore depuis 2012 nous savons tous
combien une fiscalité élevée même pour
de l'ouham visé redistributrice peut
entraîner la paralysie notre économie
nous savons tous combien excès de
sophistication l'initiative même pour
éviter des effets de seuil où certaines
incertitudes juridiques peut tuer un
secteur d'activité aussi des
interventions du x factor sans vouloir
les surévalué peuvent décider de
l'avenir d'un secteur d'activité mais
aussi de la dynamique qui anime notre
économie or ces propositions de loi est
un formidable cas d'école d'une
tentative de réglementations d'une
activité économique nouvelles à ce sujet
on pourrait parfois se demander si les
dispositions soumises à notre examen
relève tout du domaine de la loi je
n'entrerai pas dans ce débat même s'il
n'est pas complètement illégitime
dans le cas présent nous avons à faire
un secteur d'activité anciens le
transport léger de personnes dont le
modèle économique est remis en question
par une offre nouvelle comme souvent les
nouvelles technologies sont derrière
cette offre comme souvent les nouveaux
entrants sur le marché sont de
redoutables concurrents pour les
entreprises historiques et comme souvent
leurs concurrents c'est d'autant plus
d'où table que ces nouveaux entrants
bénéficie d'un cadre légal et
réglementaire beaucoup plus avantageux
que les entreprises historiques qui ont
parfois payer au prix cher leur monopole
le débat que nous avons aujourd'hui est
donc très similaire à celui que nous
pourrions avoir avec le secteur de
l'hébergement ou la rude concurrence que
se livrent les hôteliers et les
plateformes communautaires de location
et de réservations de logements
particuliers ce débat ressemble
également beaucoup à celui que nous
avons eues sur les auto entrepreneurs à
l'occasion de l'examen de la loi
relative à l'artisanat aux commerces et
aux très petites entreprises dans
chacune de ces situations
le transport de légers de personnes
l'offre d'hébergement où les auto
entrepreneurs nous avons d'un côté des
entreprises qui se voit soumise à des
obligations légales et réglementaires
très contraignant en plus de
dispositions fiscales très lourde et de
l'autre côté des gens entreprises
innovantes qui ne font qu'exercer le
plus strict du droit d'entreprendre
comme la constitution le leur permet
voilà pourquoi ce texte revêt un
caractère symbolique fort rose croire
que personne ne tombera dans le piège
d'une lecture binaire où il faudrait
choisir entre la défense d'intérêts
économiques ancien au nom de l'asus
régulation de l'économie et le rejet de
toute réglementation au nom de la
liberté d'entreprendre pour ma part il
ne fait aucun doute qu'il existe plus la
loi du 22 juillet 2009 de développement
et de modernisation des services
touristiques un problème évident de
rationalisation de l'offre de transport
léger de personnes les vtc bénéficie
d'un cadre légal très avantageux par
rapport aux taxis et taxis père leur
licence jusqu'à 200 maisons pour paris
le prix de la licence connue a connu une
chute relative ces derniers mois
puisqu'il s'était élevée jusqu'à
250 milles et tout à l'heure on a
entendu des chiffres plus élevés encore
que cela de leur côté les vtc peignent
un matricule et assure renouvelable tous
les trois ans 200 euros
en contrepartie de cette distorsion
l'état qui bénéficie du monopole de la
maraude n'ont donc payer pour bénéficier
de leur monopole le développement des
smartphones et d'applications permettant
de mettre en liaison en relation vtc et
clients par un dispositif de
géolocalisation rendu l'activité des vtc
extrêmement entame du fait de temps
d'attenté entre deux courses très faible
dans les mains le même temps les taxis
se voient imposer des clauses exclusive
par les centrales de réservation qui les
empêche de petits immigrés leur activité
l'intervention des pouvoirs publics
n'est plus souhaitable mais
indispensable sans exagération aucune je
crois que la coexistence des taxis des
vtc n'est effectivement pas viable si
chacune de ces deux catégories conserve
son modèle économique
fort de ce constat le groupe ump est
arrivée à la conclusion que la coalition
des taxis vtc devait passer par trois
principes la modernisation des taxis la
consécration de leur monopole en ce qui
concerne la maraude et enfin
l'encadrement de l'activité des vtc
notamment en matière de tarification des
immatriculations mais qu'ils ne viennent
pas artificiellement parasites et leurs
activités en ce qui concerne la
modernisation des taxis le groupe ump
est en accord avec les auteurs de la
proposition de loi l'article 1er est la
création de ce registre de disponibilité
des taxis nous semble une avancée
importante
mais l'autre con avancées du texte sans
laquelle surgissent de disponibilité
taxi aurait été un feu de paille réside
dans l'air
l'interdiction dans l'interdiction faite
aux centrales de réservation d'empêcher
aux taxis d'utiliser ce nouveau système
où tout système privé qui valent ans il
est essentiel que les taxis comblent
leur retard en matière de
géolocalisation
cet article premier est une étape
importante
nous nous prononçons également faveur de
l'article 1er bis qui vise à permettre
le paiement par carte bancaire d'un et
taxis en intégrant dans la définition de
ses véhicules l'obligation d'être muni
d'un terminal de paiement électronique
embarquée en état de marche
l'incertitude pour les clients
consécutive de l'absence de ces
terminaux nuit à toute la profession sur
le long terme cette mesure sera
bénéfique aux taxis de la même manière
mon groupe et moi même sommes en accord
avec la cessibilité de la licence
cette modernisation des taxis est un
préalable indispensable au maintien de
leur monopole pour la maraude il serait
inconséquent de maintenir
artificiellement en vie des acteurs
économiques qui ne sont pas en mesure de
satisfaire une demande de plus en plus
exigeante
revenons-en au deuxième principes qui
doivent guider notre action la
concentration du monopole des taxis en
ce qui concerne le marché de la maraude
l'article 8 propose de modifier
l'article l 31 21-11 du code des
transports afin de sanctuariser le
monopole des taxis sur le marché de la
maraude dans leur zone de rattachement
cela ne convient très bien
malheureusement dans ce même article 8 à
l'alinéa 22 disposition pour le moins
qui est temps de se glisser la
proposition de loi prévoit ainsi qu'il
est interdit aux voitures de transport
avec chauffeur et à leur intermédiaire
entre guillemets d'informer un client
avant la réalisation la réservation
mentionnées au 1 du 2 du présent article
quel que soit le moyen utilisé à la fois
de la pérennisation et la disponibilité
immédiate ou prochaine d'un véhicule
c'est nathan wynn las fallas qu'aucune
reprise avait conclu rapidement en
d'autres termes voitures de transport et
chauffeurs n'ont plus le droit
d'utiliser despotique dispose-t-il 2-2
et localisation et pour cacher cette
aberration qui revient à tous et
d'activités vtc il donne la position
devant nous parle de lutte contre la
maraude électronique s'il convient de
saluer rapidement la pirouette
sémantique que co titulaire l'invention
d'expression marotte électronique ces
dispositions est le parfait exemple de
ces nouvelles entreprises dont on entend
dans notre activité sans aucune raison
rationnelle
sauf à considérer qu'il s'agit d'acheter
la paix sociale
pourtant les nouvelles de mesures
afférentes à les motivations des vtc aux
articles 6 et 7 nous semblait acceptable
dispositions relatives à la facturation
toujours l'article 7 avait également ne
mérite de conserver une certaine
souplesse la qualification se fera soit
par un forfait soit par une location la
durée sur le modèle des ex grande remise
à l'excès du palu exclusion de tout
tarification kilométrique 2 lequel les
textes je donne ma conclusion madame la
présidente sur lesquels le texte nous
sommes plutôt sur la bonne voie aussi
aussi madame la présidente
et pour conclure je vous indiquerai que
nous avons comme d'autres collègues de
notre assemblée
déposer quelques amendements qui visent
à améliorer ce texte et c'est au vu du
texte qui sortira nos travaux que le
groupe ump déterminera sa position pour
le vote final je vous remercie de
l'attention
merci monsieur le sénateur
madame la ministre vous m'avez demandé
la parole je vous la donne bien
volontiers
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs juste pour
apporter quelques précisions
tout d'abord concernant l'urgence de ce
texte
des taxis également j'en prends ce genre
de rencontre et on rencontre aussi
l'organisation professionnelle est quand
même là il ya clairement une attente
très forte d'avoir un texte très
rapidement cela jeu quand même je
voudrais le rappeler après vous pouvez
tout à fait faire remarquer pour que
pour le travail parlementaire la
procédure d'urgence présente certains
inconvénients et je peux entendre
concernant la demande de la profession
il y à vraiment des pressions très
fortes une attente très forte de la
partie les taxis sur paris et également
dans les grandes métropoles
cause
in east vous avez seule la vente
d'objets
longs qu'ils demandent à ce que cette
loi sortent rapidement c'est cela
non mais attendez alors je retire je
veux tenir s'il vous plaît c'est le
dessinateur je retire le terme pression
jeu il sut préférées bien sûr je
reprends la phrase les professionnels
souhaitent qu'il y ait rapidement et de
façon ils souhaitent aussi de façon
insistante à ce qu'il y ait une
proposition de loi qui soit adopté c'est
une réalité que je 4ème je tiens à
rappeler
concernant toujours les professions donc
des professionnels et des taxis rappelé
que dans le cadre des annonces qu'a pu
faire le ministre de l'économie et du
retracement productif et du numérique
concernant les professions réglementées
les taxis n'ont pas été mentionnés vous
pouvez reprendre ses déclarations les
taxis sont mentionnés dans le rapport de
ligier frp pas mais pas dans les
propositions faites par arnaud
montebourg
concernant également
donc les
autorisations qui ont été délivrés de
façon récente rappelé qu'il avait été
demandé à atout france de suspendre il
ya de ça un certain nombre de mois qu'il
était difficile de pouvoir maintenir
cette suspension je comprends monsieur
le rapporteur
votre mécontentement de ne pas avoir été
tenu informé et jeu et je le regrette le
gouvernement aurait dû en effet vous
vous en informer je vois là je suis
désolé que cela n'ait pas été fait
sachez que cette décision avait pris un
thé vite prise bien sûr un niveau
interministériel et qu'elle était
nécessaire par rapport aussi aux 2000
demandes qui sont en attente donc comme
vous l'avait indiqué il ya 800 nouvelles
autorisations et 65 renouvellement d'où
le chiffre de 135 c'est à dire quand je
parle des
et 2000 demandes ixion attente ce sont
2000 nouvelles demandes en attente donc
pour l'instant il y à 800 qui ont été
débloqués et en effet ce qui avait été
décidé c'était à partir
de la mi juillet qu'on autorise et atout
france à reprendre ses instructions la
concernant après les effectifs de la
dgccrf
comme tout membre de gouvernement nous
savons qu'il est difficile de faire des
choix lors de leur établissement d'un
budget qui lie à une nécessité d'avoir
des mesures fortes pour diminuer la
progression de la dette en france des
efforts sont demandés à l'ensemble des
concitoyens aux collectivités locales
également aux administrations d'état
concernant la dgcrf vous donner quelques
précisions que sur le budget 2014
les effectifs ont été augmentés de 15
personnes et nier quelque temps plein
qui ont été accordés sur cette
administration et de plus d'avoir cette
proposition de loi cela permettra
d'avoir des contrôles plus efficaces de
la part de nos agents et ensuite
concernant les licences rappeler que
c'est le nouveau régime qui est prévu
dans cette proposition de loi qui
s'appliquera pour toutes nouvelles
délivrance de licences donc nous avons
bien pris en compte cette remarque qui a
été fait le texte de la proposition de
loi est bien sûr ce dispositif là que
nous ne prolongeant pas le précédent
dispositif issu de la loi de 95 de
pasqua mais nous sommes pour les
nouvelles licences sur un nouveau
dispositif qui je pense
améliorera le fonctionnement de cette de
cette profession et surtout dans nos
rangs des relations plus saines et plus
clair
merci madame la ministre la discussion
générale est close nous passons donc à
la discussion du texte de la commission
je vais mettre trop voir l'article 1 il
n'ya pas d'explications de vote
sur cet article donc qui est pour cet
article 1
6 6 7 7 qui est contre
qui s'abstient
cet article est adoptée même vote sur
l'article 1 bis
nous en arrivons à l'art ti après
nous sommes je suis saisi d'un
amendement 6 rectifiée présentée par
monsieur capo canellas
volontiers même la présidente le
président parle de ministres et chers
collègues le rapport remis par thomas
thévenoud en avril dernier pour mulet
une trentaine de propositions la 9e
d'entre elles a été de généraliser le la
possibilité de règlement par carte
bancaire sans minimum c'est à cette
mesure que correspond l'article 1er bis
de la proposition de loi à l'heure
actuelle pouvoir payer par carte bleue
ou tout simplement manière électronique
sa course de taxi semble être un service
qui doit être mis à disposition des
clients et ce n'est pas un luxe que de
le proposer
on sait que nous pouvons payer par carte
bancaire sans contact la baguette de
pain mais
la moitié du temps pas son taxi et ça
semble effectivement être anachronique
donc nous saluons l'introduction de cet
article 1er bis qui est utile néanmoins
nous voulons rester vigilants quant à
son application juste vis-à-vis des
clients cette fois certaines compagnies
de taxi souhaite semble-t-il appliquer
des majorations aux clients qui
utiliseront la carte bleue de l'ordre de
1 euro au prétexte que ce mode de
paiement a un coût pour le chauffeur
cela ne paraît pas acceptable même si
l'éventuelle existante cette majoration
serait d'ordre réglementaire nous
souhaitons nous en prémunir en prévoyant
dans la loi que les tarifs appliqués
pour le transport de personnes ne
peuvent pas varié en fonction du mode de
paiement utilisé il s'agit ainsi d'
assurer une véritable égalité des
particuliers face aux tarifs appliqués
je remercie merci monsieur le sénateur
avis de la commission monsieur leur
apport tard
oui l'article 1er
1er bis à généraliser les terminaux de
paiement par carte bancaire
dans tous les taxis ce qui veut dire on
circulait que le paiement par carte
bancaire sera désormais possible dans
n'importe quel véhicule c'est cet
amendement vise à préciser que non
seulement pour les taxis il aussi pour
les vtc le fait de payer par carte
bancaire ne puisse pas justifier une
majoration clairement il me semble non
chers collègues que cet amendement est
en réalité satisfaits et n'apporterait
rien au droit existant en effet
aujourd'hui la tarification des taxis
qui est fixé réglementairement ne dépend
pas du moyen de paiement utilisé de
nombreux taxis sont d'ailleurs d'ores et
déjà équipés de ce type de terminal ce
qui n'induit pas une majoration de leurs
tarifs pour les vtc non plus la
tarification ne dépend pas du mode de
paiement d'ailleurs tous les paiements
se font demain de manière dématérialisée
par prélèvement automatique
je vous propose
mon cher collègue de retirer votre
amendement car elle est satisfait au
fond
sinon la commission donnera un avis
défavorable donc je demande un retrait
c'est possible
je vais quand même demander d'abord
demandé l'avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre
merci la présidente comme monsieur le
rapporteur lundi que le droit positif
répondent déjà à la préoccupation
exprimée par cet amendement en effet
selon l'article elle le sent
12-12 du code monétaire et financier
le bénéficiaire d'un paiement ne peut
appliquer de frais payeur pour
l'utilisation d'un instrument de
paiement donné il ne peut être dérogé à
cette interdiction que dans des
conditions définies par décret pris
après avis de l'autorité de la
concurrence contenu la nécessité
d'encourager la concurrence de favoriser
l'utilisation de moyens de paiement
efficace donc un effet sur le sénateur
je pense que vous pouvez vous pourriez
envisager le retrait de cet amendement
puisque l'apôtre préoccupations tout à
fait légitime est satisfaite par cet
article du code monétaire et financier
et bien sûr nous sommes attentifs à ce
qu'ils soient bien entendu respecter
monsieur le sénateur capo canellas nous
on vous a posé une question vous allez y
répondre volontiers même la présidente
j'ai entendu avec intérêt les réponses
que même la ministre et monsieur le
rapporteur viennent de nous donner je
voulais simplement qu'on soit bien clair
dans ses réponses pour moi le point
important c'est que la disposition
réglementaire qui va intervenir
concernant les tarifs devra veiller à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de différence selon le
mode de paiement vous me dites qu
aujourd'hui à disposition qui fait que
normalement il ne peut pas y avoir de
différence je souhaite qu'à l'avenir la
disposition réglementaire qu'ils soient
prises respecte clairement cet
engagement
auquel cas je retire madame la ministre
vous réponds passionne et je vous
confirme que nous respecterons bien
entendu cet engagement est sûre
cet article qui est bien entendu
indispensable qui comme fondateur sur
toutes les transactions qui peut y avoir
en matière de paiement
merci madame la ministre donc
l'amendement 6 rectifier le tir et nous
en arrivons à l'article le premier ter
avec un amendement numéro 22 rectifié
monsieur capo-canellas si vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente cet
amendement propose réécrire l'article
1er terre et par là même d'élargir le
champ d'application du rapport au
parlement prévu par cet article il
concerne l'utilisation par les taxis de
la faculté créé pour eux de transmettre
leurs informations de localisation et
disponibilité au registre national les
problématiques a traité doit être plus
large selon nous est concerné l'ensemble
de l'offre de mobilité on a vu dans la
discussion générale que plusieurs
orateurs ont insisté sur ce point il
nous semble qu'il ya un équilibre à
trouver entre taxis vtc autopartage ou
encore voitures en libre service et il
nous faut surtout pas opposer les uns
aux autres au contraire nous proposons
développer l'offre de mobilité pour
élargir le marché et répondre à la
demande des particuliers et puisse faire
aussi sans doute que les véhicules
particuliers sont moins en moins utilisé
mais l'offre globale de mobilité
partagée le soin dont ce rapport nous
permettra d'adapter ensuite notre
législation à ses conclusions mais il
nous semble que c'est nécessaire
merci monsieur le sénateur pour la
commission avis du rapporteur
mais madame la présidente donc c'est un
an dans visa prévoir que le rapport
remis par le gouvernement au parlement
sur l'utilisation du nouveau ruciste de
disponibilité et taxis par les
chauffeurs fasse également état de
l'évolution de la demande dans ce
secteur
la commission a donné un avis favorable
à cet amendement qui apporte une
précision utile donc avis favorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
le gouvernement s'est engagé à mettre en
place prochainement un instrument qui
répondra à l'objectif poursuivi par cet
amendement conformément aux
préconisations faites par monsieur et
nous en effet la proposition numéro 12
du rapport prévoit la création d'un
observatoire national placé auprès du
ministre chargé des transports qui
servira à partir des données locales
d'outil statistique de suivi et d'un
quête de l'activité des taxis des vtc
les transporteurs léger de voyageurs les
productions de cet organisme seront
notamment disponibles pour les
législateurs la mise en oeuvre de cette
mesure s'effectuera donc par voie
réglementaire
avec ce nouvel outil de réflexion plus
approfondie pourra s'engager sur la
délivrance des ads qui relève dans
l'état actuel du droit sauf pour les
taxis parisiens de la compétence des
communes et à partir du 1er janvier 2015
également de la compétence de certains
jeux pc donc je la réponse que je vous
apporte en fait
répondre à votre préoccupation par une
autre voie que celle que vous proposez
mais au niveau du gouvernement nous
entendons le la particularité l'acuité
de la question que vous vous posez donc
nous vous proposons de le retirer à
défaut ce sera un avis défavorable
alors je vais donner la parole à
monsieur capo-canellas ce
vous laisser la parole d'abord à
monsieur bizarre alors monsieur le
président bézard vous avez la parole si
vous voulez bien la prendre
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous avons
là un amendement qui a reçu l'aval de la
commission est en fait le véritable
argument c'est que madame la ministre le
gouvernement veut un vote conforme je
rappellerai je leur dirai pas 10 fois
que en ce qui nous concerne nous sommes
opposés à ce vote conforme et il ya la
procédure qui a été suivi nous avons une
proposition de loi qui en fait est un
projet de loi mais ça permet d'éviter
les inconvénients du projet de loi 1
un auteur de la proposition de loi dont
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il
n'a pas été très courtois vis-à-vis de
la haute assemblée il y a quelques jours
puisqu'il nous a qualifiés de majorité
ringarde et en fait
et en fait
vous avez là un amendement qui est une
amélioration
la commune la commission la commission
le dit et c'est justifié et vous nous
répondez
avec toujours la courtoisie qui est la
vôtre mais le gouvernement va faire un
observatoire national vous savez les au
comité les observatoires
les commissions multiples et diverses
que l'on multiplie ces dernières années
au niveau de l'exécutif tout en nous
disant qu'il faut simplifier
et un observatoire ça coûte plus que en
rapport les rapports d'ailleurs on se
demande si il arrive un jour ou l'autre
un mais on peut estimer que là c'est
quand même un moyen un moyen d'avoir une
indication et ça coûtera moins cher
qu'un observatoire national car on ne
résout pas et je pense que c'est à
transmettre au plus haut au plus haut
niveau de l'état on ne résout pas tous
les problèmes en disant nous allons
créer un observatoire un haut conseil
aux comités où toute une série de
d'organiser à sion d'autorité plus ou
moins indépendantes qui coûte très cher
et qui ne servent strictement à rien
merci monsieur le président mais art la
parole est à monsieur le sénateur canon
merci madame la présidente en quelques
mots pour dire d'abord que je tâche
beaucoup de prix aux avis et aux
observations de notre collègue
rapporteur et beaucoup d'entre nous
avons loué son talent lors de la
discussion générale et je me joins à ces
remarques extrêmement favorable sur le
travail qu'il a qu'il a fournie et donc
c'est très volontiers que je suis moi
l'avis du rapporteur qui est favorable
sur cet amendement je m'en réjouis je
pense que c'est utile pour la discussion
parlementaire c'est utile pour la
sérénité du débat que le parlement se
saisisse de son droit d'amendement et
nous simplement dire que jacques mézard
le président jacques mézard à l'instant
par les doors
je rien à ajouter à ce qu'il a pu dire
donc évidemment je maintiens cet
amendement et je le soumets à votre voix
de sagacité je pense que faire
progresser un texte en discussion
parlementaire c'est admettre aussi que
lorsqu'une commission émet un avis eh
bien les parlementaires s'en saisissent
et vote merci merci
je vous la donne
simplement évidemment je suivrai l'avis
du rapporteur n'ayant pas de compétence
dans ce domaine mais quand même juste
une petite remarque c'est quand même
étrange de demander au gouvernement un
rapport sur l'application de la loi je
croyais que c'était du rôle du contrôle
des parlementaires de faire ce genre de
rapport et n'ont pas demandé à
l'exécutif un rapport sur ce qu'ils font
sur ce que fait l'exécutif c'est sur la
forme simplement mais je comprends les
arguments qui monsieur le président ce
n'est pas d'autres demandes de parole
donc je vais mettre au voir cet
amendement numéro 22 rectifié qui a
eu un avis favorable de la commission
une demande de retrait qui n'a pas été
fait donc un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement est adopté
et l'article est ainsi rédigé article 2
qui est pour
et qui est contre
l'article 2 est adoptée article 3 un
amendement numéro 15 présenté par madame
cohen
merci madame la présidente les
chauffeurs de taxi qui subissent la
location ne sont ni des artisans au sens
du décret du 10 juin 1983 ni des
travailleurs indépendants au sens des
réglementations en vigueur ni des
salariés sauf à faire requalifier lors
leur contrat par la juridiction
compétente ce qui a été nombre de fois
le cas notons mes chers collègues que
cette condition de surexploitation avait
été abolie d'ailleurs il faut le noter
par le front populaire en 1936 est
reconduite par la droite dans les années
70 sans doute pour réduire le périmètre
du droit au travail et augmenter le
profit de quelques-uns l'extension
l'établissement de contrats de location
6000 à paris a contribué à déséquilibrer
la structure de ce secteur économique
ainsi ont été supprimés les chauffeurs
de relais qui sortent les véhicules
pendant les périodes de repos
hebdomadaire congés annuels et autres
temps d'absence des chauffeurs des
milliers d'emplois ont ainsi disparu au
cours des dernières décennies et cela se
répercute négativement sur la qualité du
service rendu aux usagers et la sécurité
de tous structurellement la continuité
du service rendu ne peut pas être
assurée avec le système de la location
et cela se ressent particulièrement dans
la capitale et sa banlieue les vtc se
sont engouffrés d'ailleurs dans cette
faille structurelle
compte tenu de ce que je viens de dire
l'abolition de la location nous convient
d'autant que c'était un combat qu'avait
mené notre groupe par la voix de nicole
borvo cohen-séat dès 1998 mais nous
pensons que le système de locataires
gérants ne résout pas le problème que je
viens d'évoquer il continue à vouloir il
continue à vouloir nier le lien de
subordination qui existe entre les
loueurs et les locataires rappelons
également que le locataire gérant comme
le locataire ne sont ni propriétaires de
leur outil de travail en l'occurrence
leur véhicule ni titulaires de la
licence de taxi de plus le locataire
gérant contrairement aux locataires
actuels ne seraient pas couverts par
rapport à un éventuel accident du
travail du fait de son affiliation au
régime social des indépendants
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi nous nous
déposons cet amendement et il est par
ailleurs indispensable que l'actuelle
convention collective soit renégocié
pour la rendre plus attractive et
protectrice pour les chauffeurs salariés
je vous remercie merci madame la
sénatrice pour la commission à vis de
monsieur le rapporteur
dumas chers collègues lé la proposition
de loi vise en effet à privilégier les
chauffeurs de taxi ont mettant fin aux
situations injustes et source de
précarité c'est pour cela que tout les
louves les nouvelles licences qui seront
délivrées à partir de la promulgation de
la loi
les titulaires ne pourront plus les
exploiter
du tout en location que ce soit la
location simple ou la location gérance
ils ne pourront plus que l'exploiter
directement ou en recourant au salariat
vous proposer avec votre abandon d'aller
plus loin
encore puisque vous préconisez que
toutes les licences déjà délivré
exploités sous le statut de la location
ne soit plus exploités du tout en
location y compris la location gérance
ce que prévoit pourtant le texte je
crois que cet amendement va un peu trop
loin dhr circonstante nous sommes
actuellement risquerait 2 est
déséquilibré toute une profession qui
d'ailleurs était demandeuse d'un
étalement dans le temps de la
suppression d'allocations c'est ce
qu'ils nous ont dit lorsque nous avons
rencontré maintenant la location-gérance
correspond au régime général
d'exploitation des fonds de commerce par
un tiers indépendant et permet à leurs
bénéficiaires d'être
davantage protégés grâce à ce statut les
chauffeurs de taxis pourront être
représentés au sein des organisations
professionnelles de taxi et auront droit
à l'indemnisation chômage
c'est d'ailleurs ce statut de locataire
gérant qui est privilégiée partout en
france à l'exception à paris à
l'exception de paris
enfin un délai supplémentaire a été
adoptée à l'assemblée nationale pour
permettre à la profession de s'organiser
le délai c'est 2017
fin 2017 pour toutes ces raisons même si
je comprends votre démarche pour toutes
ces raisons la commission a donné un
avis défavorable pour cet amendement à
moins que vous décidiez de le retirer
merci monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
en complément des arguments développés
par monsieur le rapporteur rappeler que
l'activité de locataire à taxi est très
différente de celle de salariés taxi
l'activité de locataires taxi est
majoritairement exercées par des
conducteurs qui espère gagner plus
d'indépendance en accédant à la ds pour
ces derniers la proposition de loi
prévoit deux mesures fortes le passage
au statut de la location gérance qui
leur permettra de devenir artisan comme
cela été développé avec tous les
avantages et donc d'atténuer la
subordination et le loueur et l'accès
prioritaire aux nouvelles ads taxi qui
peuvent actuellement être attribués à
des spéculateurs qui ne cherchent pas à
exercer le métier dans ces conditions
imposées à des conducteurs ayant choisi
l'indépendance en fait devoir y renoncer
je pense que la mesure qui est par en
effet d'une intention louable aurait un
effet pervers qui serait quand même
assez regrettable donc je pense qu'il
serait plutôt nécessaire de retirer et à
défaut ce sera un avis défavorable du
gouvernement
merci madame la ministre monsieur de
sessa pour une explication de vote
mais présente j'ai beaucoup apprécié les
propos du rapporteur qui nous a bien
précisé que avec les nouvelles licences
il pourra plus y avoir de
location-gérance ce sera obligatoirement
celui ou celle qui a la licence qui
devra conduire le taxi et
on parle maintenant des licences
existantes dans les compagnies qui
ont acheté des licences ou acheter la
voiture à 4500 euros peu importe
nombreux de course ne peut importe le
nombre d'heures travaillées mais nous on
l'a loué on loue la voiture et la
licence qui au départ devait être
gratuit ce dès le droit de travailler
voilà quatre mille cinq cents par mois
alors et on comprend le texte il dit non
ça on veut plus du
de locataires du taxi locataires et ont
fait ce que vous appelez la location
gérance mais la question qui est posée
on a bien compris qu'il y avait un
système un statut plus avantageux
la question que je vous poserai monsieur
le rapporteur au madame la ministre
c'est qu'est ce qui garantit
que ça soit plus l' esclavage qu'est ce
qui garantit qu'on demandera pas à ce
locataire gérant la somme de 4500 euros
parce que c'est ça qui va déterminer
dans dans le statut d'artisan il n'y a
pas de limite horaire donc c'est une
forme mais on va dire un peu plus
fin et on met des règles pour
l'esclavagé mais enfin c'est entre
guillemets mais on peut si on demande à
la personne la même somme 4500 euros ça
veut dire des heures de travail du
stress la personne la qualité du service
ou là et d'ici là personne stress et
d'un pas d'argent mais c'est quand même
dans le dans le taxi on s'en ressent
elle est moins disponible et veut faire
le maximum enfin elle va plus vite elles
accueillent moins bien donc qu'est ce
qui nous garantit que nous ce nouveau
statut de gérance de locataires gérants
sera pas une forme d'exploitation qui
continueraient qui serait un peu plus
dans les normes on va dire sociale mais
qui serait quand même de l'exploitation
qu'est ce que nous le garantis seraient
la question est est ce là déterminerait
mon vote si monsieur le sénateur à cette
question monsieur le rapporteur
nous sommes actuellement sur un jeu peut
pas garantir complètement je serai je
serai pas il faut rester modeste mais je
crois que l'objectif c'est d'arriver à
cela avec le temps évidemment puisqu'il
existe et il existe actuellement des
licences qui ont été délivrés delà de la
manière dont vous l'avez rappelé dans
notre intervention d'hier qui ont coûté
très cher il faut qu'il faut respecter
ces gens-là met un terme petit à petit
elle devrait disparaître voilà c'est le
sait le sait la décision qui a été prise
c'est vrai que dans la suggestion vous
avez fait dans votre intervention d'une
reprise à terme
ça n'a pas été
pris en compte dans le rapport thévenoud
peut-être que peut-être qu'un jour on
revient on remettra ce ce dossier là sur
le sur le
parlement pour aller au fond comme vous
l'avez suggéré d'ailleurs dans votre
intervention que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
monsieur le rapporteur madame cohen vous
avez été sollicité pour retirer votre
amendement co répondez vous moi je
trouve que les explications qui ont été
donnés sont sont intéressantes pour pour
mieux appréhender effectivement les
dispositions qui sont prises mais en
même temps elle montre les limites de
cette proposition et c'est pour ça que
l'amendement que nous proposons au
niveau du groupe crc d'un amendement de
protection effectivement comme le dealer
le rapporteur c'est pour aller plus loin
c'est pas tellement pour aller plus loin
c'est pour être plus protecteur est allé
quand même dans l'esprit que moi j'ai
ressenti à la lecture de cette de cette
proposition de loi c'est pourquoi nous
maintenons un autre amendement merci
madame la sénatrice je vais donc mettre
on voit cet amendement numéro 15 qui a
recueilli deux avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
et qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement n'est pas
adopté je vais voter l'article 3 qui et
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient l'article 3 est adopté
nous en arrivons à l'article 4 g une
demande de parole de monsieur le
sénateur yves pozzo di borgo oui mais
madame la présidente mes chers collègues
le ce rapport et c'est pas une critique
parce que je sais qu'il a fallu le faire
très rapidement et on est beaucoup de
compétences pour comporte une faiblesse
c'est que dans ce rapport n'est pas reçu
la direction des transports et la
direction de l'ordre public de la
puissante préfecture de police qui gère
les deux cinquièmes texier des taxis de
france
je sais je m'adresse aux administratifs
vous avez reçu les membres des cabinets
ministériels des transports comme de
l'intérieur mais moi même et amante et
les longtemps membre dans les cabinets
ministériels n'ont pas du tout les
compétences des services et le regrette
qu'on n'ait pas reçu ces deux directions
je vous rappelle sa maman ce qui
concerne paris qui actuellement 17700 de
taxi licence de taxi dans 15 cents
doublage qu'est ce que sont les
doublages et doux lâché simplement comme
un taxi fait 11 heures par jour
évidemment la nuit si on laissait sur
l'essai cela ne pourrait pas avoir de
taxi la nuit laissait doublage et des
casses en double à ça permet à certains
taxis d'avoir 11 heures puis son heure
ce qui permet de travailler la nuit
je vais dire aussi et c'est quelque
chose de très important pour la société
pour l'équipe la société c'est que le
métier de taxi est un métier la dernière
chance
c'est vraiment les gens d'un deuxième
génération qui s'intègrent c'est le
cadre qu'a mis toutes ses économies pour
être taxi c'est le cas des russes à
l'époque vers les russes quand bien
marquer paris puisque la police des
tissus et taxis s'appelle l'éboueur
parce qu'à l'époque les chauffeurs taxi
russe quand ils voyaient ce qu'il appelé
les flics en russe disait aux herbes ou
air et d'ailleurs les lébous air qui
sont toujours de comptes entre koné
moyens je dis ça parce que c'est un
élément très important d'intégration les
taxis ces raisons pour moi qui suis un
élu parisien a mis un terme à tour
eiffel aussi je considère que c'est
comme la tour eiffel taxis sont des
éléments de la vie de paris
alors j'en reviens maintenant à
l'article 4
la direction de la préfecture
les directions danger cités des deux
préfectures se sortent elles qui délivre
les autorisations et les licences
aurait eu des rapports rapport attali
rapport en disant qu'il fallait beaucoup
plus de qu'il fallait beaucoup plus de
licence on a comparé avec new york on a
comparé avec l'inde il faut savoir qu'à
paris les services de transport sont
beaucoup plus développés quand ces
villes il faut savoir sur l'ombre c'est
un le grand londres c'est pas du tout
les deux millions d'habitants qui vient
là paris et que tant que si la
préfecture de police titi donne vraiment
au compte gouttes les licences de taxi
c'est qu'elle a ses raisons elle sait
très bien que depuis dix ans la
circulation à paris est passée de 20 km
heure à 15 de plus en plus difficultés
de circulation elle sait très bien que
ce soit un nombre plus important de taxi
vous n'aurez pas plus de taxis sur
l'autoroute saouler à paris entre 16
heures et 18 heures ou le matin parce
que vous avez une circulation intense et
c'est pas du tout parce que j'aurai
10000 vtc de plus que vous aurez
beaucoup plus de vtc ou de taxi donc
cette préfecture et des compétences
extraordinaires pour gérer cela
deuxième élément gens regardent ce que
je disais et que la licence de taxi est
un élément d'intégration sociale de la
dernière chance pour beaucoup de monde
pour des gens de la deuxième génération
un peu beaucoup de monde
la licence actuellement il s'est créé un
marché stini sens gratuite
mais collège kouassi les essarts disait
qu'elle devait valoir que seulement 230
me l a baissé depuis l'arrivée des vtc
puisque si vous voulez ça fait marcher
je suis pas d'accord avec ce que dit
aimer le rapporteur le chiffre
d'affaires global des transports btc
taxi n'a pas bougé à paris au contraire
l arrivée des vtc a fait baisser le
chiffre d'affaires des taxis très
important de tenir compte de ça et c'est
une erreur de dire ça j'ai contesté le
rapporteur je lui ai dit gentiment mais
c'est une erreur faut bien laisser les
choses parce que maintenant de plus en
plus à paris vous avez les velits vous
avez les autolib vous avez beaucoup plus
autre chose qui permette que fait que le
marché de taxi de marche et respect syfy
qui s'entendaient très bien d'ailleurs
avec les voitures de remise qui étaient
les tester avant il y avait aucun
problème ce qui a déstabilisé les choses
c'est le système hubert vous avez une
société qui a investi 2 milliards à san
francisco classe c'était google qui
investissent sur hubert et qui
déstabilise un petit peu le chauffeur de
taxi et ça fait quand paupérise si on
laisse faire le système hubert on va
paupériser les chauffeurs de taxi et les
chauffeurs de taxi ce témoin
d'intégration et je dis pourquoi cela
soit dix ans je suis pas d'accord cet
article 4 parce que d'abord vous aurez
très peu de licences qui sont donnés à
paris je parle de paris parce que le
problème sera la même la direction qui
gère tout cela donne aura très peu de
licence actuellement il ya un marché
prochain taxi 17 ans a travaillé
vraiment 11 heures par jour je peux vous
dire c'est pas être un facteur des
fonctionnaires j'étais fonctionnaire je
peux le dire et encore quand il faut 35
heures je suis en colère je peux le dire
je critique pas du tout là mais ses 11
heures par jour par 17 ans au bout de
sept ans ils peuvent avoir une licence
ils ne peuvent lasser déco bout de 15
ans et là ils ont leur retraite c'est
leur faim peu de retraite complément de
retraite sa vie d'avoir une concrète où
ils sont paupérisés et moi je regrette
si vous voulez que cet article daté lieu
on aurait dû continuer du mois paris je
ne sais pas le reste de la france mais
je pensais aussi la plus valable on lui
redonne dire de laisser ce système parce
que le nombre de licences ne manquera
pas même s'ils sont libres parce que ce
sera direction l'a prévenu la police qui
limitera le nombre est au contraire
s'ils avaient ce marché ça permet aux
taxis après on est vraiment des années
de labeur de travail d'arrivée d'avoir
une retraite un peu décente et d'avoir
un petit capital qui leur permet de
quitter la vie active et ce à raison
pour laquelle je suis contre cet article
si monsieur le sénateur je mets donc on
voit cet article 4 qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet article iv est adopté
article 5 même votre
article 6 même vote nous en arrivons à
l'article 7 avec trois amendements en
discussion commune d'abord celui numéro
16 présenté par madame cohen oui
mesdames la présidente par cet
amendement nous demandons simplement de
revenir sur la mesure qui prévoit la
possibilité pour les vtc 2 faire payer
leurs courses selon une tarification
horaire en effet alors même que
l'objectif de cette loi est de
distinguer l'offre des taxis de celle
des vtc afin de les rendre réellement
complémentaire force est de constater
que leur permettent d'adopter le même
mode de tarification que les taxis ne
permet pas de remplir cet objectif de
clarification il peut également induire
en erreur les usagers a fortiori nous
vous l'avons déjà dit nous craignons que
l'interdiction de la maraude pour les
vtc soit difficile à faire respecter
faute de moyens humains pour effectuer
ce contrôle de cette manière comment les
usagers pourront s'y distinguer un taxi
d'un vtc si en plus la tarification est
effectué de la même manière notre
amendement est en fait un amendement de
clarification tout simplement qu'ils
participent pleinement à la réalisation
des objectifs qui sont définies par la
loi merci madame la sénatrice
amendement numéro 10 rectifié de
monsieur capo canellas
merci même la présidente mes chers
collègues l'article 7 fixe le nouveau
régime juridique applicable aux vtc et
encadre la tarification des services de
vtc pour les exploitants et des
intermédiaires le principe est celui
d'une tarification forfaitaire
déterminé avant la course au moment de
la réservation préalable le prix peut
toutefois être calculé en partie après
la réalisation de la prestation s'il
dépend uniquement de la durée de
celle-ci et à condition que l'entreprise
et communiquer au client le mode de
calcul du prix et des éventuels frais
supplémentaires cet article est-ce que
donc tout tarification purement
kilométrique la détermination du prix la
course effectuée par une voiture de
transport avec chauffeur doit pouvoir
être effectuer librement et dans la
transparence selon des critères les plus
adaptées c'est pourquoi en complément la
durée de la course il semble pertinent
de pouvoir prendre en compte la distance
parcourue comme le propose cet
amendement
merci monsieur le sénateur amendement
numéro 13 rectifié bis madame escoffier
la présidente c'est
cet amendement
s'ils ont peut-être encore admettre
l'interdiction d'une fixation du prix de
la prestation en fonction de la distance
parcourue en raison de l'utilisation de
dispositifs de mesure non contrôlée la
détermination du prix en fonction de la
durée ne présente pas de risque pour le
client qui peut aisément le vérifier
lors de la réservation préalable qui est
obligatoire pour les vtc sous peine
d'encourir des sanctions pénales le
client est informé du prix des
conditions de l'exécution du service
conformément d'ailleurs à l'article l
113 3 1 du code de la consommation est
donc important de souligner conformément
à la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel que la loi ne peut
apporter à la liberté d'entreprendre qui
découle de l'article 4 de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et des citoyens
des limites liées à des exigences
constitutionnelles ou justifiée par
l'intérêt général qu'à la seule
condition qu'il n'en résulte pas
d'atteinte disproportionnée au regard de
l'objectif poursuivi
ainsi le renvoie à un décret ce que je
voulais faire valoir pour fixer les
modalités de calcul du prix paraît
excessif au regard des objectifs
poursuivis
savoir la protection des consommateurs
ou encore le maintien du monopole des
taxis sur la maraude les prix doivent
être déterminés par le jeu de la
concurrence qui s'exerce encore sur le
marché de la réservation préalable la
disposition vise et est issue d'un
amendement présenté à l'assemblée
nationale en séance ayant recueilli un
avis défavorable du ministre de
l'intérieur et avis que je me plais à
lire parce que monsieur bernard
cazeneuve disait dans son intervention
la proposition de loi établit un
principe simple que des précisions
apportées par voie réglementaire ne
ferait que compliquer artificiellement
rappelons que toute intervention en
matière tarifaire doit être strictement
justifiée pour ne pas être contraire au
droit de la concurrence
voilà qui est dit et que je reprends
avec un certain plaisir voilà et je dois
dire donc que
le ministre lui-même estimé que la
fixation d'une durée minimale de
prestations seraient censurées par le
juge voilà le sens de l'amendement que
nous avons présentée merci madame la
ministre sur ces trois amendements en
discussion commune l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
bien concernant l'amendement 16 proposés
par madame cohen et le groupe et les
membres du groupe crc
sa maman vise à supprimer la possibilité
accordée par le texte ou vtc de tarifs
et leurs prestations soit au forfait
avant la réalisation de la course soit
la durée après la prestation motif que
cette disposition entretient la
confusion avec le régime des taxis
cette suppression est souhaitable
comme vous le savez la spécificité de la
tarification est acquis des taxis tient
largement au compteur horokilométrique
présent dans les véhicules en fonction
de la vitesse de circulation des taxis
c'est le tarif kilométrique où le tarif
horaire qui s'applique dans le droit
actuellement en vigueur les vtc
peuvent facturer au kilomètre parcouru
ce n'est pas normal et le texte répond à
cette anomalie en leur interdisant la
tarification kilométrique en revanche
maintenir la possibilité de tarif et à
la durée se justifie en effet les vtc je
pense en particulier
aux vtc historiques sont la grande
remise sont parfois amenés à effectuer
des prestations sur plusieurs heures
d'affilée voire des journées entières et
les nécessaires de leur laisser la
possibilité de continuer à tarif est de
cette manière donc de travailler
par ailleurs je vous rappelle qu'un
décret devra fixer la durée minimale à
partir de laquelle ce mode de
tarification est possible c'est en
quelque sorte un garde-fou c'est
pourquoi je vous propose de rôles de
retirer votre amendement faute de quoi
ce sera un avis défavorable
qui a été un avis qui a été adopté par
la commission
concernant le l'amendement numéro 10
présentée par monsieur capo-canellas ce
cet amendement rétablit la possibilité
pour les vtc de tarifs et leur
prestation qui les marque a parcouru
la tarification kilométrique est l'un
des éléments centraux de l'activité de
taxi avec le compteur horokilométrique
dans le droit en vigueur les vtc peuvent
facturer au kilomètre parcouru
ce n'est pas normal je le dis une fois
de plus et le texte répond à cette
anomalie en leur interdisant la
tarification kilométrique je ne crois
pas souhaitable de revenus avec cet
amendement sur l'interdiction de cette
de la tarification kilométrique est
important de bien différencier les
activités des taxis des vtc un
tarification au forfait et sur certaines
conditions à la durée permet au btc une
certaine souplesse suffisante
en l'état la commission a donné un avis
défavorable
concernant le troisième amendement celui
présenté par notre collègue
1 marie escoffier
quelques commentaires si vous le
permettez cet amendement supprime le
renvoie à un décret
pour fixer la durée minimale deux
prestations à partir de laquelle la
tarification la durée peut s'appliquer
type une suite de ce que je viens de
dire un instant sur les commentaires des
autres amendements
cette précision avait été introduite par
l'assemblée en séance par le rapporteur
l'idée était de mieux distinguer les
courses au bout les courses au forfait
contre le réservoir et ablement
raisonnablement excusez-moi calculé à
l'avance et les courses plus longues
pour lesquelles il fallait introduire
une modulation qui tiennent compte de la
durée c'est également une demande forte
des vestes des vtc historique qui
réalise très souvent des prestations de
long dur la commission a donné un avis
favorable
je me soumets
merci monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis du gouvernement dans l'âme la
ministre sur ces trois amendements
discussion commune
concernant l'amendement déposé par
madame cohen l'amendement le numéro 16
le rappeler que le principe du forfait
est clairement réaffirmé dans la
proposition de loi qui ne prévoit qu'un
seul et unique éléments de souplesse
utile clairement pour des voitures de
grande remise pour vraiment les
fonctions un peu historique ces voitures
de grande remise qui sur un secteur très
haut de gamme ne se confondent pas avec
des taxis et propose des prestations
très particulière sur des très longues
durées et il n'y a jamais eu de problème
de concurrence avec les taxis lors de
toutes les discussions que nous avons pu
avoir avec les organisations
professionnelles de taxi ils ne nous ont
jamais sollicité sur ce point là
donc la détermination du prix de la
prestation en fonction de la durée est
ainsi utile correspond à une prestation
très particulière et qui ne remet pas en
cause le monopole des taxis ni le
principe général du forfait donc il me
semble que dans l'esprit vos
préoccupations satisfaite je vous
propose de le retirer concernant
l'amendement numéro dix déposées par
monsieur capo canellas
là nous sommes sur un autre dispositif
l'article 1 alinéa aux pardons de
l'article 8 la proposition de loi
prévoit déjà une dérogation au principe
de la tarification au moment de la
réservation ou le prix est déterminé en
fonction de la durée de la prestation au
lieu d'être terminée lors de la
réservation préalable et donc le
principe de la tarification des
dissidents correspondent à leur mode de
commande l'assouplissement que proposent
l'amendement rendrait caduc ce principe
en généralisant les possibilités d'y
déroger à tout moment pour tout motif et
là il me semble qu'il ya une ouverture
qui est trop forte de la sorte en
faisant glisser un calcul de prix qui
peut varier en cours de prestations on
adopte un régime tarifaire proche de
celui des taxis et là on entretient il
me semble le cogne fusion qui seraient
préjudiciables qui ne correspondrait pas
aux spécificités des prestations soient
des vtc soit après des taxis donc nous
vous prenons sommes défavorable à cet
amendement
et concernant l'amendement numéro 13
rectifié déposée par madame escoffier
messieurs mézard et qui est tropéano
nous avons en effet comme vous l'avez
rappelé madame la ministre
fait part de remarques très forte lors
du travail à l'assemblée nationale du
travail législatif
nous avons qu'un effet émis des réserves
et sur le plan juridique et comment vous
avez vous l'avez avait rappelé les
propos de monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur le gouvernement souhaitant
une adoption rapide du texte propos et
donc et propose un avis défavorable à
cet amendement
merci madame la ministre
y at il des demandes d'explication
malam escoffier on avait la parole
madame l'âme
ne comprend pas bien la conclusion que
vous apportez à votre propos en même
temps vous reconnaissez que le ministre
15,9 lui-même allé dans le sens de du
débat que nous venons d'avoir donc qu'il
qu'il allait qu'il le soutenait et en
même temps vous dit finalement nous
voulions un avis conforme donc je donne
un avis défavorable madame la ministre
nous avons déjà adopté un premier
amendement
donc le texte déjà n'est plus conforme
alors je ne vois pas quel est l'objectif
qu'elle l objection que vous pouvez nous
opposer étant entendu que ça correspond
je crois et il a rappelé quand même à
des règles de droit d'une part et
d'autre part à un accord qui a été dit
par le ministre lui-même en séance à
l'assemblée merci madame escoffier je
vais donc mettre aux voix l'amendement
numéro 16 madame cohen vous avez été
sollicité vous le maintenez alors deux
avis défavorable sur le moment 16
présenté par madame cohen qui est pour
si qui est contre merci mes chers
collègues d'abstention l'amendement
n'est pas adopté
monsieur quatre blocs année la maman
numéro 10 rectifié deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
merci qui est contre merci mes chers
collègues abstentions il n'est pas
l'adopter l'amendement 13 rectifié bis a
reçu un avis favorable de la commission
et un avis défavorable du gouvernement
qui pour
mercy qui est contre
abstention la maman est adopté
nous arrivons à deux amendements
identiques faisant l'objet d'une
discussion contenu monsieur
capo-canellas vous présenter le 9
rectifier
oui mais mena président qui m'est cher
collègue cet amendement concerne
toujours la question la tarification des
courses des vtc la commande sous forme
de réservation préalable peut faire
l'objet d'un forfait et le prix de la
prestation peut être déterminé à
l'avance mais des modifications peuvent
intervenir après le début de la
prestation à la demande du client par
exemple ajout d'une destination ou d'un
trajet est donc impossible de connaître
le coût total de la prestation la
réservation il est également impossible
de calculer le prix qu'en fonction de la
durée de la prestation et donc il nous
semblait que le prix devait être
déterminé en fonction la durée la
distance
une demi-journée complémentaires pour un
trajet de 300 kilos mais ne peut être
facturé comme une demi-journée
complémentaires pour un trajet en ville
par exemple ces cas sont exceptionnels
il convient de les prévoir tout en
précisant que le client en est informée
préalablement sa disposition nous
semblait indispensable pour refléter la
réalité des coûts
supporter alors cela dit il faut
peut-être que nous regardions les
conséquences de l'amendement précédent
qui vient d'être votée j'avoue contre
temps je n'ai pas eu l'occasion de me
pencher mais monsieur le rapporteur et
l'équipe de la commission d'avoir un
éclairage plus rapide que je ne pourrai
de fournir moi même sur ce point
merci monsieur capo-canellas le 18 est
présentée par monsieur relevé
le ministre notre collègue capo canellas
vient de défendre ce même amendement
mais attire l'attention que il nous
paraît très juste et est souhaitable que
dans des cas exceptionnels le prix de
certaines prestations ne qu'il peut être
calculée uniquement fonction de la durée
il faut donc qu'il conviendrait de
prévoir ces cas en sachant que le client
les 1,6 c'est cet aspect on est informé
préalablement et donc ça me parait
respecter les règles et donc c'est
pour ça que je défends cet amendement
merci monsieur rêver monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission sur
ces deux amendements identiques
la présidente écoutez nous avons une
commission durable qui est très qui
parle beaucoup il ya une grande
discussion sur ce sujet
oui mais c'est bien en même temps donc
ce sont deux amendements identiques je
vais donc faire un commentaire pour les
deux bons cet amendement prévoit que les
modifications et ajouts au cours de la
prestation par le client plein saturé
selon les conduisent le des conditions
prédéfinies le moment suivant de charles
revêt et identique donc
simplement je rappellerai que enfin des
arguments qui rappelait en commission
finalement l'argument de deux de
l'imprévisibilité de certaines courses
nous a été longuement
évoquée lorsque nous avons eu les
auditions mais très vite nous sommes
aperçus que son tour ce sont des
pratiques minime qu'il nous paraît
vraiment
presque pas normal de les mettre dans un
dans ce texte de loi
alors sous secoué mais franchement on a
vu dans je répète ce que j'ai dit
charles en commission c'est vraiment
très rare et c'est très compliqué de le
prendre en compte ce texte dans
franchement sous couvert d'avant plus
sous couvert d'apporter une réponse à
des situations qui sont
exceptionnellement rare tu vois donc cet
amendement aussi comme une porte ouverte
à une tarification
horokilométrique pour les taxis donc moi
j'appelle l'assemblée qui est souvent
très sage d'être ça sur cet amendement
qui peut paraître de bon sens mais qui
en fait bien sûr mais c'est bien normal
d'ailleurs et on comprend qui peut
paraître de bon sens mais qui en fait un
peu piégeux donc je je propose comme la
commission d'ailleurs un avis favorable
pour les deux amendements
heureusement que j'ai des assistantes
qui sont très attentives envoyée mais
tant mieux tant mieux tant mieux ça veut
bien dire qu'on travaille en équipe mais
qui sont défavorables mais merci
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre sur ces
amendements identiques madame la
présidente ma réponse sur portera en
effet sur les deux amendements
comme vous l'indiquez un effet il y à
des touristes qui ont des prestations
qui demande un peu déçu reconnaissent
exceptionnel mais dans les faits c'est
cette prestation exceptionnelle sont
réalisés et elles sont au niveau du
volume des courses qui sont réalisés
tous les jours à paris ou dans les
grandes métropoles elles sont vraiment
très marginale donc actuellement nous
arrivons à répondre à ses demandes en
l'état du droit actuel donc je vous
propose de retirer cet amendement parce
que comme l'indiqué monsieur le
rapporteur le diable peut se cacher dans
les détails et en effet avec cet
amendement on peut ouvrir la porte à une
dérive qui peut être vraiment très forte
et qu'on peut vraiment être sous-estimée
donc moi je vous promets je pense que
avec
la législation actuelle nous pouvons
répondre dans ces cas très particulier
qui sont nécessaires pour ceux des
touristes qui ont des demandes de
prestations très haut de gamme est allé
dans cette la voie que vous proposez à
votre amendement nous vous ouvrirons
d'ouvrir une boîte de pandore
qui risque d'être vraiment
très présente mieux
dit madame la ministre donc j'entends
une demande de retrait ou défavorable
monsieur k pour koné là vous maintenez
votre moment vous maintenez me suis
relevé également donc je vais le mettre
aux voix deux avis défavorables qui est
pour
merci qui est contre
merci mes chers collègues abstentions
ils ne sont pas adoptées le 1 rectifier
c'est monsieur pause de dix banques il
présente
d'andré
la proposition de loi prévoit
l'inscription des vtc dans un régime
enregistré gionale pour remplacer les
matricules à sion dans un registre
national frêche est née roth qui est moi
tant la rédaction pour remplacer
l'immatriculation auprès d'atout france
pourquoi j'ai fait ça mandement c'est
vrai qu'actuellement qu'il y aura ce
registre national tous les vtc
s'inscriront à ce registre national on
l'a bien vu d'ailleurs monsieur le
rapporteur tout à l'heure vous étiez
plutôt en colère avec on dire quelqu'un
de très modéré vous n'êtes pas exprimer
une colère me lançant t'es au fond de
vous en disant comment on traite ce
problème là et puis vous avez atout
france qui donne 865 autorisation de vtc
donc on sent très bien que sa bouillie
en vous mais comme quelqu'un de très
modéré ça s'est vu alors venez à
l'horizon je fais c'est que vous avez
beaucoup d'événements dans toute la
province qui existent moi je prends
l'exemple saison les les taxis du
manquement tiré attention à dessus ils
m'ont dit nous c'est vrai que sur
l'année c'est plutôt calme plat on
vivote monde s'en sort pas trop mal et
puis quand arrivé avec quatre heures du
mans et bien on fait notre recette pas
ce que dit pas de l'année mais au moins
ça nous conforte le revenu c'est pareil
pour le festival de cannes c'est pareil
pour je sais pas ce qui a toulouse la
ministre comme événement qui peuvent
attirer
l'activité des taxis se manquer ce qui
se passe c'est que maintenant et bien
quand lé 24 heures du mans gratia le
festival de cannes quand y aller
festival d'avignon eh bien vous avez des
flottes de taxis parisiens de vtc parise
abandon qui débarque de vtc parisien qui
débarque et qui rafle le marché des
taxis alors c'est un peu surprenant
comment à lui de paris je sois obligé de
défendre mes collègues de province mais
c'est pour ça que les festins amendement
pour essayer de protéger au moins une
nouvelle région qui vont se mettre en
place et dire écoutez éviter quand même
si vous voulez que kylie et ça c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai déjà proposé
cet amendement je ne sais pas ce que la
pensée la commission des ministres mais
c'est plus pour l'intérêt des
provinciaux que les parisiens merci
chers collègues l'avis de la commission
n'est sûr à porter sur cet amendement
avec 6
n'allons pas faire un débat entre les
parisiens et les provinciaux y compris y
compris ceux du du val de loire géant
jean-pierre bien donc oui c'est sûr pour
répondre à la demande de monsieur pause
et du borgou et monsieur capo-canellas à
cela maintenant numéro un il prévoit
d'interdire ou vtc d'exercer leur
activité hors de la région du régime
dans lequel sont inscrits ils opérerait
ainsi une sectorisation
de l'activité
devait et c'est
vraiment je paraître désagréable mais je
ne pense pas que ce soit souhaitable la
logique qui souffre qui sous tend
l'ensemble du texte est de mieux
distinguer les activités de taxi et vtc
c'est vraiment une architecture l'une
des artistes secteur du texte qu'on vous
propose
en sectorisant les vtc ont fait de
l'immatriculation une sorte de licences
alternatives ont créé une procédure
parallèle qui s'apparenterait à
l'immatriculation de taxi ce n'est pas
le souhait de certains des taxis que
j'ai rencontré d'ailleurs quand l
exemple donné du festival de cannes je
crois que les règles
d'ailleurs j'ai eu cet exemple là dans
les rencontres audition que nous avons
eues
mais bon ça m'a paru un peu folklorique
je crois que les règles désormais prévue
dans la loi en matière de sanction de la
maraude électronique très importants
notamment permettront de répondre à
l'avenir à ces situations qu'il faut
évidemment éviter
qu'elles continuent d'être exercé comme
vous l'avez rappelé il faut prendre
garde de rester sur un bon équilibre
pour atteindre d'une part une bonne
réglementation d'activité des vtc
d'autre part nous développement l'emploi
dans ce secteur la commission qui en a
là encore longuement débattu a donné un
avis défavorable
merci messieurs rapporteur l'avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
du gouvernement a le même avis que
monsieur le rapporteur qui a développé
vraiment tous les arguments c'est à dire
qu'il faut avoir une position
d'équilibré et cet amendement delà
n'aurait pas une certaine équité il
serait vraiment plus tôt avec des
régimes très différents et à ces
inégalités entre taxis et vtc donc nous
proposons qu'ils soient retirés ou sinon
avis défavorable merci madame la
ministre monsieur pozzo di borgo vous
êtes sollicité pour un retrait
je suis pas convaincu parlons de votre
argument monsieur le rapporteur parce
que le vtc me paraît le parent est allé
sans problème mais manifestement comme
je sens qu'il ya pas vraiment soutien de
toute la province d'amran à ma mort je
veux leur tirer pour éviter d'avoir
le 14 rectifie terre c'est monsieur
lézard qui présente
monsieur le président vous avez la
parole mais prenez votre temps
merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
par cet amendement
c'est une demande de suppression de
l'alinéa 20 en effet la proposition de
loi telle qu'elle est telle qu'elles
arrivent ici exige des exploitants de
voiture transports avec chauffeur la
justification de capacité financière
défini par décret nous conscients même
que c'est une demande qui est assez
original et si l'on si l'on se réfère
d'ailleurs aux usages dans un certain
dans la dans l'immense majorité des
professions c'est même strictement
atypique atypique et et au moment
d'ailleurs où on veut développer un
certain nombre d'emplois je crois que
sauf s'il y avait des raisons que nous
n'avions pas bien assimilés ou qui ne
nous ont pas suffisamment été expliqué
vu le peu de temps qui a eu le
gouvernement pour nous faire comprendre
le bien fondé de cette mesure je crois
que il est quand même excessif d'en
arriver là et nous proposons donc la
suppression de cette exigence merci
monsieur présent mais un monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission sur
cet amendement 14 à rectifier terre
merci madame la présidente monsieur
président méar jeu je vais commenter
votre votre amendement qui a lui aussi
donné l'occasion d'un débat intéressant
en commission je rappelle que le texte
prévoit l'obligation pour les vtc de
disposer de capacités financières
définies par décret cet amendement
souhaite supprimer cette obligation
motif qu'elle constituerait une entrave
à la liberté d'entreprendre il faut
rappeler que la condition de capacité
financière consiste pour une entreprise
à disposer des ressources financières
nécessaires pour assurer la mise en
marche correct et la bonne gestion de
l'entreprise c'est un principe ce à
dire que cela constitue une entrave à la
liberté d'entreprendre
pas exact n'est pas exact c'est une
exigence tout à fait ordinaire pour les
entreprises quelles qu'elles soient en
particulier c'est préférable en
particulier dans le domaine du transport
qu'il s'agit du transport routier ou
deux personnes je ne prendrai qu'un
exemple à l'oti la loi d'orientation des
transports intérieurs de 1982 prévoit à
son article 7 toutes les entreprises
sans ordre public de personnes doivent
justifier de conditions d'honorabilité
professionnelle et d'un an de capacités
financières et de capacité
professionnelle selon des modalités
fixées par décret en conseil d'état or
un des objectifs de la ppl est
précisément de prévoir un socle commun
de règles pour les véhicules
lotis les vtc ou encore les taxis
l'obligation capacités financières ne me
paraît donc pas aberrante et permettra
d'assainir aussi le marché donc après un
dialogue sain et et fructueux nous avons
proposé à madame
anne marie escoffier qui est membre de
la commission durable de retirer cet
amendement sans cela la commission donne
un avis d fort défavorable si monsieur
le rapporteur madame la ministre l'avis
du gouvernement sur cet amendement
oui juste bien rappeler en effet à
monsieur le président que dans le
secteur du transport public de personnes
ces dispositifs sont classiques et comme
l'a rapporté monsieur le rapporteur les
entreprises dites loti doivent justifier
de 1500 euros par véhicule cette
exigence permet de s'assurer de la
solidité financière des entreprises et
également de lutter contre les
immatriculations dit dormantes qui
peuvent correspondre les entreprises qui
n'ont pas le réel activités donc ce
n'est pas une entrave à la liberté
d'entreprendre mais c'est au contraire
une garantie sur un secteur qui présente
des enjeux d'intérêt général
merci madame le ministre donc c'est un
avis défavorable ou un retrait c'est
bien ça un avis défavorable merci
retrait vous êtes sollicités monsieur le
président
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre moi j'aimerais en savoir un peu
plus c'est à dire puisque vous prévoyez
de le faire voir décret avec puisque
vous considérez qu'il faut assimiler
cela aux transports publics même si ce
sont karim pas c'est pas exactement la
même chose et parce que aussi
le ministre montebourg souhaite quand
même
faire échec aux
aux professions réglementées je voudrais
savoir quel est le montant que vous
envisagez
parce qu' il peut y avoir une logique si
c'est
tout tout dépend en fait du montant est
ce que c'est un montant totalement
dissuasif ou c'est un montant pour
éviter des des inscriptions qui serait
dormantes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous souhaitez répond
vous rappeler que dans les propos et
d'années donc déclarations tenues par
monsieur le ministre de l'économie du
redressement productif il n'a pas été
mentionné les taxis les taxis sont
évoqués dans les articles des échos qui
ont mieux accès à certaines parties du
rapport doligé f rapport qui n'est pas
dire pour l'instant le public
arnaud montebourg sur les professions
réglementées a parlé d huissier a parlé
des greffiers auprès des tribunaux de
commerce
il n'a pas cité les avocats aussi n'a
pas cité en effet les taxis donc il n'ya
pas de dispositif prévu voilà à court
terme sur cela concernant le montant qui
sera évoquée dans le décret il pourra
peut-être s'inspirer un effet du montant
qui est dans le cadre des entreprises
dites lotis mais il y aura dans tous les
cas une concertation qui sera menée donc
il n'y a pas à ce jour de mon temps
décidé de vous le dire au nom du
gouvernement on pourra en effet
s'inspirer d'un dispositif qui existe
déjà mais il y aura de la concertation
pardon
c'était c'était un arbitre et un
conseiller 1500 euros maintenant même
forme que ça a été arbitré dans
récemment donc ses 1500 merci madame la
ministre
monsieur monsieur le président au
bénéfice de ses explications est-ce que
vous retirer votre amendement que je
bénéfices je sais pas si c'est le mot
qui ont bien
non je ne vais pas le retirer parce que
le gouvernement gouvernants qui
d'ailleurs qui reconnaît qu'il s'agit
pas d'une proposition de loi d'ailleurs
par par les observations que nous avons
de madame la mise mais qu'il s'agit bien
oui non mais
nous voyons bien que vous avez le
contrôle total de ce texte ceci ce n'est
pas une critique madame la ministre
c'est une constatation mais s'inspirer
de ce qui existe en transports publics
c'est pas pour moi une réponse précise
donc
par principe je maintiens l'amendement
merci monsieur le président monsieur
capoue reconnaît là
il va la prison brièvement d'observation
d'abord je pas être tellement saisi que
la préoccupation du président mézard
avait trait aux professions réglementées
j'ai entendu la réponse vint la mini sur
ce point mais il me semble que c'etait
pas forcément l'intention par contre je
comprends et je salue la volonté qui est
exprimé par cet amendement parce que
comme l'a rappelé tout alarie photos dit
bruce ce genre de métiers sont des
métiers qui sont des métiers
l'intégration et bien souvent pour celui
qui va acquérir un véhicule par exemple
si on lui demande en plus d'autres
garanties financières il ya un point au
delà duquel finalement on va faire que
ce type d'activité ne pourra pas être
accessibles à des populations pour glee
c'est aussi une planche de salut pour
qu'il y ait un équilibre qui est pas si
simple que ça a trouvé et je comprends
que le débat ait lieu sur le montant des
garanties financières qui sont demandés
il faut sans doute qu'il y en ait il
faut pas qu'ils aient de
précarité financière de la structure
parce que ça pourrait poser les
difficultés en cas en cas de problèmes
ou d'accidents par exemple mais en même
temps je voudrais qu'il faut on fasse
quand même que ces professions la rester
accessible
si cher collègue monsieur c'est ça
oui souvent puis une dizaine d'années
que je suis je siège on a souvent
demandé que la les décrets soient prêts
quasiment lorsqu'on fait la loi au moins
qu'on ait une idée donc c'est un peu
dommage qu'on n'ait pas une précision
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à savoir ce que
la question vous avez posé si c'est pour
dissuader
si c'est pour garantir quoi on n'arrive
pas à le savoir quelle est la précision
n'est pas apportée
sait vraiment où faut le dire clairement
c'est à dire on n'arrive pas à voir
derrière cette
ce questionnement c'est à dire sans
qu'il y ait de précisions si on veut
limiter le nombre si on veut donner des
garanties de sérieux s'il ya un accident
pour des assurances enfin on ne sait pas
exactement
donc c'est vraiment dommage de ne pas
avoir de précisions et
alors que j'étais plutôt enclin à suivre
le fan pas voter l'amendement les
imprécisions enfin questionne et on
n'arrive plus à savoir l'esprit
exactement du texte et c'est vraiment
dommage que quand même alors qu'on
voulait une copie confins conforme ça
veut dire qu'on était prêts que ces
questions là n'est pas été abordée avant
quoi aimer c'est caezar monsieur richard
si je peux ajouter un mois je veux
d'abord rendre hommage ou scrupules de
la ministre qui n'ayant pas
une indication définitive
défini au sein du gouvernement du
chiffre dont on parle ne peut pas
s'exprimer en cite un chiffre ça ça
paraît cohérent mais elle a cité un
autre chiffre qui est applicable à des
professions qui sont dans le service
public les transports et qui manipule
des engins lourds
les vtc ne seront pas des entreprises de
service public par contre elle ne sont
pas non plus des entreprises sur un
marché entièrement libre elles sont dans
un régime de police administrative c'est
à dire d'encadrement réglementaire comme
c'est le cas
des désaxés d'ailleurs de bien d'autres
professions donc il me paraît évident
puisque tout le monde va devant le juge
dans ces affaires-là
donc si gouvernement comme été l'erreur
de 6 et un chiffre qui suivant
l'expression du collègue desessard a un
caractère dissuasif ce serait évidemment
sortir de l'objet de la loi et ce décret
serait annulée donc il me semble
pratiquement 6 est sur des rails par les
principes du droit que il ne peut s'agir
que d'un montant de responsabilisation
et que s'ils étaient du même niveau que
pour un véhicule lourd évidemment le
gouvernement se trouverait face à une
difficulté
merci monsieur richard je vais mettre
aux voix cet amendement qui a eu deux
avis défavorables qui est pour le voter
qui est pour
merci qui est contre
suite
il n'est pas adopté
quatre moments faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune monsieur
capo-canellas le set rectifier
la présidente mes chers collègues nous
abordons à cet instant sans doute l'un
des problèmes majeurs que ce texte pose
preuves en sont d'ailleurs les trois
amendements identiques de suppression de
cette année linea 33 de l'article 7
7 alinéa rend obligatoire le retour à la
base pour les vtc
dès la fin d'une course ils seront tenus
s'il le texte n'évolue pas de retourner
soit au lieu d'établissement
d'exploitation de la voiture soit dans
un lieu hors de la chaussée où le
stationnement est autorisé comme un
parking par exemple je rappelle que sur
papa sur paris les parkings sont
souterrains et évidemment payant il est
important de préciser que cette mesure
ne faisait pas partie du texte initial
qu'elle a été adoptée dans la
précipitation on peut même le dira
dernières minutes proposé par le
rapporteur lors du débat en séance à
l'assemblée nationale
curieusement annoncé dans la presse du
matin d'ailleurs par le gérant d'une
société et surtout cette mesure ne
figurait en aucun cas dans le rapport
thévenoud d'avril et lorsqu on nous
parle d' équilibre il faut constater là
que le déséquilibre a été atteint
indiscutablement lorsque cette mesure a
été adoptée elle a beaucoup choqué vous
savez les chauffeurs de de vtc pour qui
cet ajout
déstabilise la profession sur le fond
même cette mesure nous interroge car
cette obligation de retour à la base est
antiéconomique et anti-écologique
d'abord anti économique parce que c'est
intenable pour la santé financière
de ces entreprises à et vous savez que
si elles doivent circuler à vide
accumuler des kilomètres
sans avoir de paiement évidemment ça
leur posera un problème économique c'est
aussi incompréhensible en termes de
développement durable
et
vouloir émettre des gaz à effet de serre
sans savoir d'obligation de le faire
c'est un point qui est tout de même
particulièrement singulier et donc
la volonté d'imposer la possibilité pour
les vtc d'enchaîner des courses
préalablement réservé n'est pas
compréhensible
au total nous vous proposons de
supprimer cette mesure
au titre du bilan carbone et au titre de
la réalité économique du retour à une
forme d' équilibre partiel et que nous
souhaiterions
retrouver j'aurai l'occasion de
maîtriser tout à l'heure sur notre
amendement si celui-ci ne n'était pas
adoptée quitte un amendement entre
guillemets de repli je vous remercie
chers collègues le 12 actifs y ait
baissé le président les harkis le voeu
qu'il présente c'est le même
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre est cher collègue
sur cet amendement qui est à g un point
extrêmement important
du ce texte nous nous comprenons tout à
fait les préoccupations des chauffeurs
de taxis sur l'existence d'une
concurrence qui l'ont qualifiée
fortement de déloyal sur le marché de la
maraude et aussi les inquiétudes que peu
circule que peut susciter le fait de
voir circuler une voiture de transport
avec chauffeur à vide mais l'obligation
de retourner à la base ou de stationner
dans un parking en dehors de la chaussée
à la fin de la prestation que cette
proposition de loi instaure résulte de
la crainte des taxis de voir certains
vtc racoler les clients ce qui est une
crainte que l'on comprend
toutefois et convient de préciser qu'une
telle pratique est sanctionné par la loi
qui prévoit une sanction pénale d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 15000 euros
d'amande et comme l'a souligné
d'ailleurs l'autorité de la concurrence
dans son avis sur le projet de décret
qui impose et on vtc un délais
d'attentes de 15 minutes entre la
réservation et la prise en charge du
client la gestion de tels comportements
relèvent de la recherche de fraude qu'il
appartient à l'état de sanctionner et
non pas de la concurrence dans la loi
établit clairement la différence entre
le marché de la maraude sur lequel le
monopole des taxis s'applique et le
marché de la réservation préalable ou la
concurrence doit pouvoir s'exercer
librement
on regarde les précautions prises par le
cadre juridique en vigueur ainsi que par
la proposition de loi la mesure qui est
prévu par cette dernière paraît
disproportionnée par rapport à
l'objectif poursuivi à savoir empêcher
les vtc de recourir à la maraude
les contrôles seront ils plus efficace
non car les vtc lorsqu ils se dirigeront
vers la base en circulant à vide se
retrouveront dans la même situation que
ceux qui procèdent à la maraude
rien ne peut les distinguer si ce n'est
qu'en les quand les arrêtant pour qu'ils
justifient d'une réservation préalable
autres
l'inutilité de la mesure si ce n'est au
niveau de l'affichage
pour répondre aux préoccupations et aux
inquiétudes des taxis celle-ci se
révélera coûteuse du fait de la
consommation de carburant
supplémentaires ou des frais de
stationnement dans un parking et mettra
en péril la rentabilité de vtc je
rappelle d'ailleurs qu'en ce qui
concerne le délai d'attenté de 15
minutes le conseil d'état on regrette
que notre collègue soit soit parti a
jugé en référé que le projet de décret
était je cite susceptibles de porter à
leur situation économique et financière
une atteinte grave et immédiate et cette
mesure aux seules vertus polluantes est
en totale contradiction avec les
objectifs de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre dont on connaît les effets nocifs
et aussi que l'on sait que c'est une
préoccupation forte du gouvernement à
juste titre aussi cet amendement vise à
supprimer cette obligation pour s'en
tenir aux équilibres arrêtés lors de la
concertation qui a eu lieu entre les
différents acteurs je vous remercie
monsieur le président monsieur revel
vous présenter le 17
merci
mam est ministre on sait que c'est le
même amendement que ceux qui viennent
des fois d'être défendus excellemment
par mes deux précédents collègues donc
je pars longer les débats et c'est les
mêmes motivations
merci chers collègues le 8 rectifié
monsieur pour se dit pourquoi monsieur
capo-canellas
c'est votre amendement de repli je pense
oui il s'agit d'un amendement de repli
qui
vise à proposer une voie pour régler
cette question difficile du retour à la
base donc je vais pas refaire la
démonstration que j'ai fait que prison
mézard et que charles revêt ont
également livré
avec leurs propres mots mais je voulais
simplement
dire que c'est un moment vise à
permettre au btc
d'exercer leur activité tout simplement
en ne les empêchant pas de prendre deux
courses successives si l on était
réservé préalablement est donc en ne
leur imposant pas de retourner à leur
base dans le cas où elles ont une course
qui va succéder à une autre et si on
peut comprendre l'intention de préserver
avait effectivement le monopole et de la
maraude et taxis donc l'inter d'hervé
décès il faut pas adopter non plus une
mesure qui interdirait ou vtc quasiment
leur existence on a rappelé tout à
l'heure l'impact économique que l or et
si elles n'étaient pas modifiées par
sept par cet amendement donc c'est
peut-être une solution qui pourrait
permettre que la haute assemblée
corrige le texte de l'assemblée
nationale mais je veux d'ores et déjà
indiqué ayant entendu plusieurs fois
madame la ministre
nous opposer à la volonté de conformité
que si cet amendement 8 devait prospérer
ça supposerait tout de même que nous
ayons de la part du gouvernement un
minimum d'intention de faire que la
version qui sortirait du sénat soit
défendue à l'assemblée nationale
et chapeau l'aide je vais demander donc
à notre commission la vie de monsieur
rapporteur sur ses 80 ans en discussion
commune
bien monsieur le président mais un
rappel juste titre que c'était un
amendement important
qui a fait l'objet là encore dans la
commission d'un long débat
heureusement d'ailleurs parce que
c'est un poids qui a été introduit à
l'assemblée nationale comme cela a été
rappelé
à l'initiative du rapporteur thomas
thévenoud cette obligation consiste pour
les vtc
à revenir
héhé je cite très exactement
au lieu d'établissement de l'exploitant
de la voiture ou
dans un lieu hors de la chaussée
où le stationnement est autorisé
donc c'est le terme exact
on met de côté le retour à la base le
terme exact c'est sur cette obligation
ne sommes participer de l' équilibre
fragile trouvé par les députés
d'ailleurs cela a été admis par tous les
professionnels une fois que la loi a été
votée la loi à l'assemblée a été voté
avec ce texte avec cet article
sur la question sensible de la maraude
parce que vraiment c'est le point bas
c'est le point sur lequel il faut pas
céder j'espère que tout le monde est
bien conscient mais cela a été dit par
mon différents collègues des différents
dans
comme l'expliqué thomas thévenoud dans
son rapport il est difficile de
justifier
que les betis et ne sont pas en maraude
lorsqu'il circule sur la voie publique
en attente de réservation préalable est
qu'ils sont en plus rendues visibles au
consommateur par des applications
smartphones
la frontière est très fine cela a été
dit par dodo l'oeil
le retour à la base arrière permet donc
je reprends terme permet de mieux
distinguer entre activité de taxi de vtc
c'est pour cette raison que notre
commission
n'a pas adopté d'amendements sur ce
point lors de l'examen du texte et c'est
pour cette raison que la commission a
donné un avis défavorable aux trois
amendements identiques de suppression 7
12 et 17
mai
nous avons une vocation d'être des élus
responsables et pragmatique
j'ai entendu les objections
de tous les bancs de tous les collègues
notamment
la mise en oeuvre pratique
pardon soulevés contre le retour à la
base arrière je reprends ce terme
c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi s'il faut
aménager cette obligation pour la rendre
acceptable pour tous
je vous proposerai d' adopter
l'amendement
numéro 8 notre collègue vincent
capo-canellas
l'objet de cet amendement est le suivant
il est dérogatoire au retour à la base
prévu pour le vtc qui disposerait déjà
d'une réservation suivante ou qui
disposent d'un contrat le liant au
client final ça vaut aussi pour le pour
les grandes remises en est bien d'accord
il s'agit d'une proposition intelligente
et réaliste elle préserve en particulier
les entreprises de la grande remise
je me répète mais c'est important de le
souligner je crois qu'il s'agit d'un
juste milieu il faut clairement marqué
l'interdiction de la maraude pour les
vtc mais il faut conserver une position
raisonnable et proportionnée
aussi je vous demande madame la
présidente de donner priorité
à l'amendement numéro 8 pour qu'on
puisse s'exprimer sur cet amendement et
si nous avons l'accord de nos collègues
eh bien nous aurons là comment dirais-je
un retour
excuse moi je reprends le retour à la
base un retour à la base qui serait
acceptable et qui permettrait je crois
donner à nos textes un contour tout à
fait intéressant et positif
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur je
suis donc saisi d'une demande de
priorités de la commission sur
l'amendement numéro vite c'est bien ça
selon l'article 44 alinéa 6 de notre
règlement la priorité de droit quand
elle est demandée par la commission
saisie au fond sauf opposition du
gouvernement quel est l'avis du
gouvernement sur cette demande de
priorité êtes favorable donc la priorité
est ordonnée donc je vais vous demander
madame le ministre votre avis sur cet
amendement 8 rectifié
est sûr et vous voulez oui sûr je
comprend l'esprit de monsieur le
rapporteur sur cet amendement numéro 8
qui peut être un amendement de repli
d'un mois je me permets cas d'alerté sur
1.6 sur la définition d'un contrat avec
le client final au point de vue
juridique
il ya quand même certaines certitudes
donc je
comprends tout à fait cette volonté mais
je pense que sur ceux là on a quand même
une fragilité juridique
sur ce point là
néanmoins je
vois les détecter le gouvernement
donnera une position de sagesse
merci merci madame la ministre donc
défavorable aux autres madame cohen nous
avez la parole
oui j'apprécie la la la position de
madame la ministre de sagesse parce
qu'effectivement je trouve que cet
amendement est extrêmement constructif
dans ce sens ou en tout cas pour ce qui
me concerne moi j'étais très gêné par le
fait qu' il fallait renvoyer et vtc
alors je vais le dire pour simplifier à
leur base je pense que derrière les vtc
il y à des emplois et que c'était un peu
la mort annoncée
à plus ou moins longue échéance donc
comme ce texte est un texte quand même
qui est un texte qui je trouve est
équilibré qui rétablit un certain nombre
de choses il me semblait que là c'était
trop excessif et par l'amendement qui
nous est proposée par notre collègue et
bien il y à une prise en compte
effectivement des revendications dtcc si
il ya une prise en compte du rôle des
vtc et tout ça dans un juste équilibre
avec des principes qui sont énoncés qui
me semble tout à fait important est
possible de respecter donc à partir du
moment je suis à la fois donc tout à
fait partisane de cette de cet
amendement est donc j'apprécie le ce
qu'a dit le rapporteur et la sagesse de
la ministre nous permet de voter à mon
avis de manière très largement
majoritaires me semble-t-il si je vois
ce qui se passe au niveau des bandes
divers et variés merci madame cohen
monsieur de ses stars
et que cet amendement sur le rapporteur
et revient vers ses bases puisque il
revient il ne perd pas la logique qui
conduisait le refus bon c'était gelé
exprimés aux débuts de lors de la
discussion générale nous voterons ce
texte d'équilibré mais disons bien que
le problème la cause principale de la
concurrence déloyale s'il y en a qui
font un travail pour 100 euros
d'inscription et les autres ils ont 200
300 mille euros à qui l'on investit et
qu'il faut qu'ils remboursent donc de
fait la concurrence sera toujours
déloyale temps qu'on règle pas le
problème de la licence donc je sais que
les nouvelles licences on pourra pas les
céder donc mais il ya quand même les
anciennes 1 et que les gens seront
toujours ils ont toujours l'impression
que lorsque quelqu'un vient proposer des
services et que l'inscription elle est
très faible et bien il y aura une
concurrence déloyale parce que les coûts
à supporter ne sont pas les mêmes donc
mais ça paraît quand même un peu bizarre
qu'on demande à des gens qui travaillent
ils ont fait une course a roissy on leur
demande de retourner à la base
ou de trouver un lieu
qui est un garage un parking ou un lieu
qui n'est pas sur la chaussée ponts mais
comme le disait le notre collègue du
groupe rds
comment le contrôler et si on dit c'est
pour interdire la marotte vous avez
précisé que c'est déjà interdit donc
qu'est-ce que cette interdiction amène
de plus
alors alors ça peut être un message mais
c'est surtout que c'est ça va devenir
que vous l'avez dit monsieur le
rapporteur très difficile à évaluer et
donc c'est une loi d' équilibre mais
j'ai bien peur que cet équilibre dure le
temps
une proposition de loi et que le
problème central qui est posée qui est
celui de la concurrence déloyale du fait
que l'investissement de départ n'est pas
le même pour un travail qui offre des
similitudes tant que ça sera pas réglée
tant qu'il y aura des personnes qui ont
trois cent mille euros à rembourser et
que d'autres c'est simplement
l'inscription à 100 euros tant que ce
problème là sera pas réglée il y aura
toujours une concurrence déloyale dans
beaucoup d'endroits et il y aura du
mécontentement et de la frustration des
deux côtés donc c'est une loi d'
équilibre nous allons voter votre
amendement l'amendement numéro 8 que
vous va dans ce sens là donc nous le
voterons mais avec l'inquiétude que cela
nuise au score tout le problème
oui merci même la présidente je crois
que c'est vrai que lors de
réunions de la commission nous avons
beaucoup discuté sur ce cet alinéa 33
et finalement il nous a semblé et notre
groupe a déposé des amendements qui
viendront derrière et qui peut être on
verra mais
deux tomberont de fait si celui est
adopté il nous a paru et je remercie le
rapporteur d'avoir demandé à priorités
que cet amendement même s'il ne couvrait
pas tôt pertes et permettait d'apporter
de une souplesse indispensable comme il
l'est comme il l'a dit et nous voterons
bien sur cet amendement et vous remercie
monsieur capo-canellas l'auteur de
l'amendement oui madame la présidente
d'abord je souhaite dire que j'ai
entendu les paroles de sagesse et le
pragmatisme de notre rapporteur et je ne
peux que me féliciter de sa clairvoyance
et salué sa liberté qui est celle d'un
rapporteur qui essaye d'améliorer le
texte et qui veille à la construction du
débat parlementaire je remercie
également madame la ministre qui a
évoqué le mot de sagesse c'est un mot
qui a du poids particulièrement ici
devant la haute assemblée
je remercie bien sûr chacun d
intervenants des différents groupes qui
dans leur diversité ont salué la
recherche justement d'une solution
d'équilibré et je ne doute pas que si le
sénat se prononce
fortement sur cet amendement ça donnera
une force au texte et je pense que l'
équilibre selon trouvera améliorée je
vous remercie chers collègues bien je
vais mettre aux voix l'amendement 8
rectifié qui est pour
merci unanimité il est adopté les autres
donc tombe
j'ai besoin de votre sur l'article 7 qui
est pour voter l'article 7
merci qui est contre l'abstention il est
adopté nous arrivons à l'article 8 avec
trois amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune monsieur k pour
cannes et là vous présenter le 11
rectifié volontiers blâme la présidence
et notamment un amendement pardon de
conséquence par rapport au précédent sur
l'article 7 puisque nous venons de voter
un amendement
et qu'il s'agit de regarder comment
ceci est intégré dans la suite de la
rédaction du texte en effet l'article 8
interdit le stationnement des vtc à la
border guard et aéroports au-delà d'une
certaine durée et donc c'est un moment
prévoit de supprimer cette interdiction
est donc cette durée pour les vtc qui
justifient d'une réservation préalable
c'est exactement la même chose que
précédemment mais cette fois c'est
s'applique aux gares et aux aéroports
donc
la réservation vous le savez c'est le
mode de travail des vtc à l'inversé des
taxis dont c'est la marotte et donc qui
vous est proposé de ne pas interdire ou
vtc d'approcher une gare ou un aéroport
ou d'y rester entre deux courses s'il
justifie de cette réservation c'est
exactement le même dispositif
je peux pas vous redonnez l'argumentaire
que dont nous venons de débattre à
l'article 7
voilà on peut ajouter aux arguments qui
ont déjà été développées la question des
retards éventuels
dus à un client qui aurait vu son vol
décalé bien évidemment où son train
décalé donc c'est un moment de
conséquence je vous remercie sa collègue
mais sur v
cet amendement va dans le même sens que
ceux que nous venons de voter à
l'unanimité
et il ne complète c'est l'objet de cet
amendement vous présentez le vent
monsieur retrouver dans la foulée le
numéro 20 vous l'avez présentez
vous venez de présenter l'amendement
identique il ya un numéro 20
il va dans le même sens et bien sûr
merci
merci je vais demander l'avis de la
commission mais sur la porter sur ces
mêmes la présidente c'est le même temps
ce même esprit que le 8 donc je donne un
avis favorable
aux 11 actifs yeoh 19 rectifier le vin
défavorable
oui
défavorable madame le ministre votre
avis
sur ce genre et j'entends monsieur le
rapporteur que vous indiquez que ces
deux le même esprit que l'amendement de
numéro 8
je sais quand même un petit peu
un petit peu moins
mais je n'ai pas exactement la même
analyse que vous sur ce sur ce sujet là
parce que je pense que de donner juste
fait d'avoir un éclairage particulier
sur les gares et les aérogares
cela est vraiment pas tout à fait dans
le même esprit puisque on est quand même
plutôt sur le stationnement dans les
gares et les aérogares avec une volonté
de toujours avoir une priorité bien
entendu forte pour pour les taxis donc
sur ce thème en demande là le
gouvernement sera défavorable merci
madame la ministre est sur le vin
également madame nice n'est pas
également je vous remercie monsieur
c'est ça
mais là je n'arrive plus à comprendre
exactement j'ai envie de faire plaisir
notre collègue en est de faire plaisir à
tout le monde ce soir je suis dans une
bonne disposition mais j'ai du mal à
comprendre lorsqu'on est à l'aéroport on
a conduit enfin lorsque les véhicules le
avec loafers
vont à l'aéroport si on prend
l'amendement des députés
ils doivent rentrer à la base où se
garer trouver une place de parking dans
les gares et dans
les aéroports il y en a donc là ça
voudrait dire qu'on les autorise les
attentes de clients on les autorise à
stationner comme s'il attendait le
client
ainsi parce qu'ils peuvent on leur
demande pas ils peuvent la basse c'est
d'accord où ils peuvent lalalalalala le
texte initial de l'assemblée s'étaient
ils peuvent là la base où ils vont dans
le parking pourquoi cette est précise et
un parking justement pour pas qu'ils
soient sur le lieu où il y avait taxé en
double file j'ai cru comprendre que
c'était ça l'esprit de la loi va de
l'esprit de l'amendement des députés
et c'est vraiment dans les gares et les
aéroports qui à la maraude c'est
vraiment dans ces endroits là où les
aînés les véhicules arrivent se garde
pas trop loin et puis ils disent on est
prêt au cas où un client qui passe et on
voit que quelqu'un qui cherche un peu
bon ben on se déplace et puis avec un
petit panneau peut mettre paris ou des
choses comme ça donc c'est ce club ce
que craignent justement les chauffeurs
de taxi donc mettant les gars parce
qu'on peut dire que c'est embêtant
lorsqu'on leur demandait de d'aller à la
base mais dans les gares et dans les
aéroports il ya des parkings donc s'il
attend la course après il a déposé
clients il va dans le parc ligne
je l'attends on l'appelle il ya son
confia le nouveau client qui arrive se
déplace donc
l'amendement qui paraît de bon sens et
tout ça dans les gares et les aéroports
je suis un petit peu en interrogation
voilà maintenant je suis prêt à voter la
l'otan fonction non pas des
circonstances mais comme je sais que
tout ça est une question vraiment daf un
équilibre ça reste toujours d'une
histoire d'applications difficile mais
je suis quand même dans les gares et les
aéroports là on peut pas dire qu'ils ont
peut que la paire ce que le la voiture
ne peut pas trouver un parking pour se
garer et attendre le nouveau contrat
merci monsieur lessard monsieur
je prends l'exemple de paris en fait il
ya quatre points 2,4 points de friction
à paris qui à la gare du nord qui ne pas
gagne pas possible qui a la garde de
liant que tu ne gagnes pas possible il
ya roissy kate une pagaille pas possible
et aux reliques est une pagaille pas
possible vous êtes simplement arriver à
carde la gare de lyon aujourd'hui
allez-y vous verrez qu'il ya un endroit
qui est limité pour les taxis à la queue
taxi pied l'endroit qui limité pour les
taxis qui sont commandés ou la cave
resté une heure où les vtc qui sont
commandés ou les motos qui sont
commandés aller à la gare de lyon vous
verrez une voiture louée hertz voir que
de remise vous verrez des motos une
dizaine de motos d'une photo là qui
n'entame pas du tout qui n'ont pas du
tout de commandes c'est une pagaille pas
possible j'ai d'ailleurs dit le préfet
de police fo des cas même plutôt que
d'envoyer sur des mid et des coûts
ponctuels qui en permanence dépendant on
a nous je pu commettre de respect la
ville de paris que l'on peut rompre et
de les mettre à part ça c'est juste une
remarque incidente mais là en ce qui
concerne l'amendement que propose que je
peux poser avec avec vincent du décès
vrai que si vous avez avait et
s'équipent à roissy il part de paris va
ainsi dans le texte actuel ce vtc soir
dans un parking de roissy ou gaz un
parking la gare du nord avec les
parkings vinci du côté du dôme coins de
paris avec un cookie conséquent n'est ce
pas ce cas facebook était un jour un
pari je vais vous dire que le coup lui
dû tacler le coût du taxi le coup dû
débarquer à paris y est chère et où et
je repars l'exemple le taxi varois si
c'est toi qu'elle est votée l'heure et
ça vous monte encore député plus longue
liste
excusez moi je continue sa saison de
plaisir je continue il va ta clivage le
taxi arrive il dépose son client à
roissy mais dans le l'amendement que
veut nous tel qu'il est actuellement il
faut qu'il revienne je sais pas si vous
imaginez
les kilomètres qui qu'il faut faire la
pollution le retour ce que tu m'en fous
et les il ya eu toujours un équilibre
d'ailleurs je le redis et c'est la
presse de police qui nous dit ça entre
les taxis et puisque la paix les
voitures de remise parce que les la
stratégie d'un poste de police et une
stratégie intelligente elle cautionnait
a laissé faire en fait l'ac profiter de
police f elle fait ce que fait
l'amendement pozzo que canelas lt ça
c'est à dire qu'elle est à la logique
des choses et donc l'idée si cet
amendement est voté ce sera tout simple
c'est vrai qu'ils pourront rester les
taxis dans la zone où ils peuvent rester
une heure enfin les vtc procès de la
zone ne peuvent rester jeune et je crois
que c'est quand même une certaine
intelligence en sachant que je sais pas
le reste de la france j'ai pas un
fromage mais que sur paris c'est quatre
points essentiellement voilà et donc
s'il s'est contenté d'un coup mais ce
cas pour année là vous voulez rajouter
quelque chose très brièvement ce qui il
faut donner beaucoup vient dire les
choses extrêmement clairement c'est vrai
que dans le cas de l'aéroport les choses
sont simples si on vote pas cet
amendement le vtc qui va amener un
client
bien qu'il ait un autre client après
devra retourner à la base ou ressortir
payer un ticket de parking pouvoir en
justifier et donc simplement dit que
quand un vtc me dépose j'en prends pas
ma faim pendant l' hypothèse vient
déposer jean desessard ap vient à
chercher dans des délais ça après dans
ce cas là effectivement il n'a pas
retourné à la base parce qu'il a amené
un client et il a une réservation auprès
là pour un deuxième client simplement
sert pas lui dire tu veux que vous
ressortez de l'aéroport vous repartez à
l'extérieur pour revenir cc c'est un cas
de bon sens même chose que tout à
l'heure c'est tout merci monsieur le
rapporteur
et je me permets décidé d'éclaircir un
peu tout ce débat qui pourrait illustrer
en fait on est sur le stationnement
devant la gare tout simplement à dire si
le taxi il a mis la main de peu le
monopole de la maraude devant la gare le
dtc s'il amène un client
avec cet amendement
si la mine un client et qu'il en a un
autre il reste devant la gare
s'il n'a pas s'il n'a pas de clients il
n'a pas à stationner devant la gare tout
simplement donc avec cette année avec
ses amis cet amendement on perd mais on
vtc 2 stationné dans la gare à la
condition d'avoir une réservation
préalable
ou un contrat pour les grandes remises
ce que le contrat client veut final
c'est plutôt un terme qu'on emploie pour
les grandes remises vont la jouer je
vais le rappeler puisque on a parlé tout
à l'heure donc c'est finalement un
amendement très simple qui permet une
meilleure praticité pour les vtc à la
condition qu'elle faisait qu'ils aient
une réservation préalable merci monsieur
le rapporteur je vais mettre aux voix
donc l'amendement 11 rectifiée présentée
par monsieur k pour année là et le 19
rectifiée présentée par monsieur revel
qui sont identiques avis favorable de la
commission
les défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour le voter
merci qui est contre abstentions ils
sont adoptés et donc le 20 ans
je suis saisie de 5 amendement faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur capo-canellas le de rectifier
est-ce qu'on peut présenter des uns
après les autres voilà avec grand
plaisir madame la présidente c'est ce
que je souhaitais vous vous proposez
donc ces amendements vienne en
discussion commune et nous abordons la
un autre sujet compliqué importante ce
texte qui concerne ce qu'on a appelé un
peu improprement la géolocalisation
jeudi improprement parce que quand on
lit cet alinéa on se rend compte qu'il
est plein d'ambiguïtés et donc
d'insécurité juridique tant dans ses
objectifs que pour les chauffeurs de
l'été c'est qu'ils devront l'appliquer
s'il est maintenu tel quel alors le
premier amendement reprendre notre
position globale que j'avais défendu
lors d'un sujet en général à savoir la
suppression de l'interdiction de la
géolocalisation pour les vtc
l'idée simplement c'est que c'est une
technologie qui est à la base même de
leur développement et qui fait leur
spécificité
s'est passé dans l'usagé commun pour les
clients c'est toujours compliqué quand
même expliquer à une profession qu'on va
lui retirer une innovation qu'elle a mis
sur le met sur le marché
cumulée au retour à la base cette
interdiction
vraiment risquerais de générer beaucoup
la profession alors le retour à la base
rien trouvé de solution et je pense
qu'on peut essayer d'en trouver une
maintenant sur la géolocalisation
alors il ya plusieurs solutions on peut
la supprimer à supprimer cet alinéa on
peut aussi réfléchir à des solutions qui
sont un petit peu plus des solutions de
compromis 1930 aux petits pots thèse que
cette mesure est un mauvais signal alors
que d'ailleurs le gouvernement affirme
vouloir développer l'innovation
numérique dans notre pays affiche et
signale que on enlève cette possibilité
cette possibilité là une profession
qu'il a introduites ça serait quand même
particulièrement bizarre
alors ça c'est l'amendement numéro 2
supprimer cet alinéa les a même pas
normand suivant maintenant sont des
solutions de repli on voit que dans le
débat parlementaire les solutions de
repli sont toujours des solutions qu'il
faut considérer parce que elles
permettent parfois de trouver des
solutions
la maman 5 et vise à maintenir la
possibilité pour un client de contacter
directement électroniquement un véhicule
mais de permettre de faire en passant
par un intermédiaire qui a développé un
vas-y dans une technologie pour attirer
les clients
l'objet est donc bien de rétablir une
valorisation du rôle d'intermédiation
commerciale des entreprises garante de
l'absence de relation directe entre le
chauffeur et le client constitutive de
la maraude apanage état ici donc c'est
de garder la géolocalisation mais
d'enlever la maraude électronique c'est
ça l'objet de cette annonce numéro 5 le
3 la rédaction actuelle de l'alinéa 22
nous semble trop floues notamment pour
la question du moyen d'information du
client utiliser le texte actuel interdit
par exemple de donner des informations
de localisation et de disponibilité par
téléphone c'est en cela que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure que cette rédaction nous
semblait particulièrement flou et donc
nous souhaitons préciser
les choses
parce que ce n'est pas l'esprit de la
mesure et c'est à pénaliser certaines
entreprises de vtc qui organise les
réservations par téléphone il faut donc
ce soit effectivement prévu il s'agit
donc de lever la sécurité juridique lié
à cette rédaction en limitant
l'interdiction aux moyens numériques
mais on peut quand même utiliser le
téléphone est loin des choses
lanfains j'en termine avec la maman
numéro 4 qui participe à une meilleure
rédaction cet alinéa en supprimant la
notion de disponibilité immédiate ou
prochaine qui n'a de sens précis qui n'a
pas de sens précis pardon et qui crée
une incertitude sur le véritable délai
définissant la proximité de la
disponibilité la seule information
totalement fiable qui peut être fournis
aux consommateurs et la disponibilité
immédiate ou non reste ne nous paraît
pas valable merci monsieur capo-canellas
le vin
chers collègues en fait cet amendement
est identique à celui vient défendre ce
cap au canada il nous précise de
préciser le demande il propose plutôt de
préciser que l'intention 17h et
d'interdire la possibilité pour un
véhicule dont propriété en l'exploitant
n'est pas titulaire de l'autorisation au
stationnement mentionnée à l'article l
31 21-1 du code des transports d'être
aidés par un client sous une forme
quelconque donc en partie pillée par
voie électronique en cliquant sur une
icône de véhicules apparaissant sur une
carte sur l'appareil 21 mai les lieux
effectué là une commande et non pas
d'interdire une plateforme de
réservation de fournir à son client une
simple information mais une information
essentielle pour organiser ses
déplacements à savoir à disponibilité au
nom des véhicules proche de son lieu de
départ est entendue c'est ensuite la
forme elle même et non le client qui
sélectionne le véhicule qu'elle lui
propose
merci monsieur v l'avis de la commission
sur cette série d'amendements discussion
commune monsieur le rapporteur
bien merci madame la présidente je je
vais m
m'expliquer sur l'amendement numéro 2
rectifiez de monsieur capo canellas
cet amendement supprime l'interdiction
de maraude électronique prévu par
l'article 8
il s'agit là d'un des principaux apports
du texte
et d'un est l'un des points durs dans l'
équilibre fragile trouvé à l'assemblée
nationale
le rapporteur de l'assemblée devant tous
les députés
la maraude électronique est défini comme
le fait d'informer un client avant
réservation et quel que soit le moyen
utilisé à la fois de la localisation et
de la disponibilité d'un véhicule quand
ils se trouvent sur la voie publique et
ne dispose pas d'une licence de taxi il
n'est donc pas juste de dire que le
texte
interdi la géolocalisation
ce qui est interdit et le fait de faire
figurer l'emplacement des voitures
et de les indiquer comme disponible
suffit de prendre un abonnement moi j'ai
j'ai mis mon doigt dessus effectivement
là on est sûr on est vraiment sur la
maraude électronique et c'est pas
possible je voulais expliqué on s'y
recoller nous en avons parlé
ce qui est interdit et le fait de faire
fuir je reviens et de faire figurer
l'emplacement des voitures de l'indiquer
comme disponible en donnant la
possibilité aux clients de héler
électroniquement la voiture de son choix
là franchement méreau qu on met en cause
un déséquilibre majeur de ce texte de
nombreuses applications aux smartphones
joue aujourd'hui sur l'ambiguïté de la
réglementation sur ce point le
dispositif proposé ici me semble
équilibré il maintient la possibilité
pour les vtc sous certaines conditions
d'utiliser les applications qui ont fait
leur succès il y en a compté 6 et cité
ce soit par d'autres sur certains bancs
kif pratique fort bien ce travail là et
bravo mais il ya des règles à ne pas
dépasser
garantie que le monopole des taxis sur
l'amoureuse soit respectée la commission
a donné un avis défavorable
madame la présidente à cet amendement
numéro
de rectifier celui que monsieur capot
canelas dit comme un amendement de repli
je dirais oui mais il est aussi grave
quoi aussi compliqué donc ces dames à
cet amendement aurait réécrit la linea
sur l'interdiction de la maraude en
supprimant ces éléments les plus
importants
l'interdiction ne porterait plus
désormais que sur le fait pour le client
de contacter directement une voiture
sans passer par un intermédiaire non
seulement ce n'est pas la définition de
la maraude électronique mais en est il
en atténue grandement la portée sur
l'année la linea bon le texte est
largement vidé de sa substance avis
défavorable concernant le 3 rectifier
cet amendement de monsieur capo-canellas
ce toujours cet amendement remplace les
mots quel que soit le moyen utilisé par
les mots par voie électronique
la maraude illicite peut prendre de
nombreuses formes c'est donc trop
restrictif nous avons la commission a
donné un avis défavorable concernant les
deux autres amendements qui sont
identiques de monsieur capo-canellas ce
et monsieur charles revêt monsieur
charon
je rappelle tout simplement que l'alinéa
22 prévoit l'interdiction de la maraude
illicites qui s'appuie sur l'implication
clients à la fois de la localisation de
la disponibilité immédiate et prochaine
d'un véhicule c'est amenant ainsi que
l'amendement voté un qui est identique
supprime la précision immédiate ou
prochaine au motif que la disponibilité
prochaine n'est pas suffisamment bornes
et juridiquement l'idée de disponibilité
prochaine est effectivement flou et donc
nous vous proposons un avis favorable
aux amendements 4,21 merci monsieur
l'apporteur l'avis du gouvernement
madame la ministre sur cette série
d'amendements
l'avis du gouvernement sur l'ensemble
des événements sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements sera défavorable car
l'occupation du domaine public par
l'étape taxi est un monopole qui est
fondateur de l'organisation de ses
missions et donc nous souhaitons
qu'il y ait un respect de ce principe et
donc nous donnons un avis défavorable à
l'ensemble des amendements je vous
remercie madame la ministre je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'amendement oui
monsieur k pour l es là
oui quelques mois le président d'autant
plus que j'étais amené à présenter
l'instant des amendements dans un même
paquet et c'est pas toujours simple pour
la compréhension
générale
d'abord je remercie le rapporteur de
l'amendement de pardon de l'avis
favorable qu'il a bien voulu émettre sur
leucate
rectifier c'est un point positif alors
on progresse et j'ai toujours envie
d'inviter le rapporteur a progressé
encore plus il va nous faire progresser
en tout cas dans la rédaction de deux de
ces dispositions qui est
quand même un sujet majeur
alors je comprend volontiers que la
maman numéro 2 de suppression vous
paraissent trop radical dont acte
je regrette que je suis prêt à retirer
le 2
je retire le 2 je regrette que la maman
de repli numéro 5 ne recueille pas plus
l'attention du rapporteur et du
gouvernement parce que
c'est une façon d'éviter clairement la
barre d'électronique et malgré tout ne
pas déstabiliser totalement le secteur
et en toute hypothèse je voudrais
rappeler que
la rédaction actuelle ne convient pas et
que avoir une disposition où il est
écrit qu'il est interdite quel que soit
le moyen utilisé
ça nous paraît choquant parce que ça
veut dire que dans ce cas là si on reste
si on adopte pas le 3 rectifier on est
sur un texte qui interdit de donner des
informations de localisation et de
disponibilité des vtc par téléphone et
on peut même pas appeler la centrale
pour savoir s'il y avait été c'est pas
loin je m'étonne qu'on puisse
sereinement discuter d'un texte sans
s'interroger à ce moment-là de la
rédaction donc voila tout moyen est
interdite nous on propose avant de dire
que c'est par voie électronique c'est la
maraude électronique qui est interdite
mais d'enlever l'expression qui est qui
et qui est particulièrement vague qui
est tous moyens
merci messieurs capo-canellas je suis
heureux du bon goût
mais j'avais un petit différend gaiement
collègue vincent capo canellas donc j'ai
pas signer son ami son
l'amendement de rectifier qui supprimer
la ligne à 22 parce que je considère cet
important et c'est vrai j'ai bien
compris c'est un cas d'un élément
important de la loi que ce qu'on
interdise en fait aux clients d'avoir
son iphone et puis de pouvoir repérer
les vtc qui sont autour c'est ça en fait
alors c'est vrai que cette proposition
est directement je sais d'où elle vient
la technique on leur a parlé avec 120
capoter la technique va faire que ça
tiendra pas longtemps mais dans un
premier temps au moins c'est un moyen
d'équilibrer ils reconnaissent exemple
auquel je n'ai pas signé l'amendement
mais par contre monsieur le rapporteur
je rejette les arguments de vincent
capo-canellas ce l'amendement de rugby
est un bon moyen de de répandre un peu à
l'interrogation de mon collègue et je
regrette que le gouvernement comme le
com vous même ne le retire pas parce que
c'est vrai que c'est pas ça touche pas à
l'extension aime forcément le lot de
cinq rectifié en réfléchissant bien ça
ne touche pas à la l'essence même de
l'art ti d'intervention de jeu de cette
géolocalisation partiel et moi je
regrette parce que c'est vrai que je dis
un sérieusement notre groupe était assez
ouvert sur les choses là on a
l'impression que sur cette affaire je
sais pas si incompréhension entre
vincent fin de monsieur cap reconnaissez
vous même mais je reviens parce que ce
que cet article à cet amendement
rectifié ayant été acceptée ça aurait
permis un vote positif du groupe ont
même si on explique dans nos
explications devant que je vois autorisé
ces textes là parce que pour les
taxistes important je ne suis pas sûre
que mon groupe suivra parce que il vous
a proposé un argument d' un amendement
de repli vous le prenez pas et je trouve
que jojo aux arguments de capo canellas
cesser cet amendement ne touche pas à
l'essence même de l'interdiction de
géolocalisation voilà merci merci chers
collègues je devais donc mettre aux voix
oui messieurs rapporteur
je voudrais rappeler que nous avons été
ouverts dans ce débat nous avons on a
fait ce qu'il fallait pour que le sénat
marc
ce texte loi met en mots en matière de
maraude électronique je pense que très
très je vous le dis très amicalement on
pourra continuer le débat parce que
évidemment ça tout ça ça va se mettre en
marche avait fonctionné bon mais je
pense qu'il ne faut pas toucher
actuellement à ce tas cette partie du
texte c'est trop fragile trop compliqué
et en même temps le les termes de les
termes de l'amendement que vous avez
déposé
ne sont pas conforme à l'idée que nous
on se fait de la maraude de la maraude
priorité pour les taxis donc franchement
c'est pas une mauvaise volonté de notre
part c'est une vision plutôt positive
du texte ou le texte qu'on vous propose
si monsieur le rapporteur je vais donc
mettre aux voix le 5 rectifié qui a reçu
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
merci contre
merci mes chers collègues abstentions il
n'est pas adopté le 3 rectifié même vote
mes chers collègues même vote je vous
remercie n'est pas adoptée le 4 actifs y
est a reçu un avis favorable de la
commission et on a vidé le 4 et eefje le
21 aussi oui je vous en prie un avis
favorable de la commission à l'avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui pour
mercy qui est contre abstentions ils
sont adoptés
nous arrivons à l'article 8 ha oui on la
met en avant
un but avait déposé un amendement madame
la ministre je vous invite à présenter
l'amendement 23 qui vient d'être déposé
par le gouvernement
la présidente j'avais oublié cette
amende jeunes qui est purement
rédactionnelles donc c'est vraiment
juste dans un souci de clarification
nice l'avis de la commission un moment
rédactionnelle je donne un avis
favorable
merci je l'aimais aux voix qui est pour
merci mes chers collègues et compte
abstentions il est adopté madame la
ministre nous arrivons à l'article 8
votre sur l'article de huit pieds pour
voter l'article de 8
merci qui est contre
abstention l'article adopté même vote
pour l'article 9
même votre mécha collègues il est adopté
même votre pour l'article 10 même vote
si vous vous entendre même vote merci il
est adopté même votre pour l'article 12
même vote attendez les willows à oui oui
pardon il y avait toute une série dans
l'es11 l'article 11 vous êtes pour il
est adopté même vote même vote l'article
11 bis même vote vous entendre l'un de
vote l'article 11 ter pareil l'article
12 pareil merci l'article 12 bis a même
bottes
l'article 13 la suppression est maintenu
je vais donc mettre aux voix l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi et je suppose
qu'il y a des explications de vote vous
serez vous avez la parole oh non ça va
être très rapide et très simple madame
le ministre
la présidente mme la présidente
c'est semble t il été un peu long mais
j'ai donné mes conclusions et donc dans
la conclusion j'ai indiqué que notre
intention première était plutôt d'aller
dans un vote négatif
mais c'est comme l'a souligné le
rapporteur il ya eu un travail très
intéressant qui étaient faits au sein de
la commission et ce soir dans
l'hémicycle et donc nous allons nous
abstenir sur le vote parce qu'il ya
quand même un certain nombre d'éléments
sur lequel nous aurions souhaité pris en
compte mais nous allons nous abstenir
merci cher collègue monsieur testons
vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente lors de la
discussion générale
j'ai expliqué les raisons pour
lesquelles groupe socialiste considère
que le texte voté à l'assemblée
nationale et équilibrée
lors des débats que vous n'en d'avoir
les amendements qui ont été adoptées ne
changent pas l'équilibré du texte le
groupe socialiste le votant je vous
remercie cher collègue monsieur
capo-canellas
oui madame la présidente à l'heure qui
est qui était celle de ce soir a vu les
appétits qui se manifeste je vais être
particulièrement bref d'abord on avait
signalé lors de la discussion générale
qui avait deux points majeurs sur
lesquels il fallait que le texte ait
évolué il ya une évolution notable dont
je remercie le rapporteur
le gouvernement pour sa sagesse et
l'ensemble des collègues pour leur vote
sur le premier point qui était le
premier retour à la base bon c'est un
élément du débat et je veux saluer le
fait que comme toujours le sénat soit
dans une logique de construction
d'amélioration des textes pour autant
sur le deuxième point qui suit la
géolocalisation malheureusement on n'a
pas pu avancer on le regrette alors le
rapporteur a dit que le débat pourrait
prospérer plus tard au total donc
mon groupe s'abstiendra sur ce texte là
il faut zoli bourgault donnera sa
position personnelle tout à l'heure mais
le reste du groupe s'abstiendra je vous
remercie monsieur k pour l eelam c2c ça
lors de la discussion générale j'avais
annoncé que les sénatrices et sénateurs
écologistes allaient voter le texte donc
nous maintenons ce vote positif pour le
texte il reste que
effectivement c'est un équilibre par
rapport à trouver pour pacifier
une situation très difficile entre les
taxis et les voitures de transport avec
chauffeur
donc ce texte d' équilibre est
intéressant de lance de bonnes pistes il
reste toutefois que la situation
des locataires même si ça plaît le plus
locataire mes
locataires gérants restent encore à
étudier et voir comment elle va évoluer
si vraiment on met fin à une situation
intolérable par notre texte ou s'il
faudra de nouveau
légiférer sur ce point là un peu pour
éviter les abus et la cause même de la
difficulté est de tout et de tous ces
problèmes c'est que certains et
certaines chauffeur de taxi doivent
rembourser le prix de la licence acheté
200 mille trois cent mille euros plus
les intérêts des emprunts donc c'est des
sommes énormes et que eux ne peuvent pas
admettre une concurrence que qe2 qui n'a
payé que un droit d'entrée de 100 euros
donc
il faut il conviendra j'espère que le
texte d' équilibre que nous allons voter
ce soir va résoudre cette situation mais
quand même la disproportion la
concurrence déloyale est encore là donc
il conviendra de voir si notre loi va
résoudre ce problème aussi conviendra de
légiférer de nouveau à ce moment là en
abordant vraiment le problème des
licences qui à mon avis le point la
cause de cette concurrence déloyale
je vous remercie monsieur de césar
monsieur pozzo di borgo
je suis pas membre de la commission qu'à
traiter ce dossier mais je voudrais
d'abord remercier de la façon du temps
de travail et j'ai pu travailler avec
mon collègue capo-canellas ci dessus
mais comme je suis évidemment élus de
paris les taxis pour moi c'est du seco
la tour eiffel les taxis de la marne
désolé ils sont là ils font partie de la
vie et donc je suis un défenseur
vif et et combative ceux des taxis c'est
la raison pour laquelle c'est vrai qu'on
a eu de longues discussions au sein du
groupe là dessus c'est vrai que le
groupe souhaitait mango centre et
souhaité qu'ils aient deux amendements 1
/ de l'article 33 l'article 7 alinéa 33
qui est acceptée je remercie monsieur le
rapporteur épicerie aussi sa
géolocalisation moi-même sa
géolocalisation je lui ai dit j'étais
beaucoup moins combatif
je considère c'est un système qu'il faut
être à pique un peu durement départ mais
qui va pas tenir compte tenu des
évolutions techniques on sait très bien
j'ai vu à quel poste de police est vrai
qu'ils espèrent que ça va fonctionner
mais on sait très bien que c'est quelque
chose de très fragile bon mon groupe à
et pris de position l'exception des jeux
j'ai je les ai je leur ai dit que moi
même j'aurais ma proposition je voterai
donc ce texte parce que ce texte
essentiellement protège et qui dit qu'il
ya toujours eu d'ailleurs à paris
important entre les taxis et les
voitures de miss qui étaient les
anciennes vtc et il n'interdit pas non
plus demander vtc avec j'espère parce
que ça c'est mon principe et je
considère que c'est un élément
fondamental de l'avenir c'est que le
rapport entre les taxis et des vtc
d'après moi de toujours rester deux à
cinq quand vous dit quand vous
déplacerez ce rapport de 1 à 5 eh bien
vous aurez déstabilisation du système je
le dis ça parce qu'on sait très bien
j'essaie de bien regarder ça je suis
élue à paris depuis 83 j'ai bien regardé
ce problème l' équilibre entre voitures
de remise est votée de taxi c'est 1 à 5
si ce rapport dépasse ça sera un
véritable problème je dis et je votre
texte merci je vous remercie cher
collègue madame cohen
oui je l'avais dit lors de
l'intervention général nous étions
attentifs au niveau du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen et à l'évolution
du débat je veux quand même signaler que
le débat parlementaire et notamment au
sénat est toujours un apport très riche
et j'appelle le gouvernement à y être
attentive et vous madame la ministre
parce que nous sommes quand même dans
encore dans une procédure d'urgence qui
vraiment ne considère pas le parlement à
son sa juste valeur si je puis dire et
on voit bien à chaque fois qu'il ya ce
genre de débat dans l'hémicycle la
sagesse du sénat quelles que soient les
sensibilités des uns et des autres
permet toujours d'enrichir le texte donc
c'est quand même une remarque que je
voulais faire et puis il ya eu des
avancées il ya eu aussi malheureusement
des problèmes que nous avons soulevés
qui n'ont pas été entendus pour cette
fois ci le seront peut-être
prochainement et notamment les moyens
qui sont nécessaires pour les contrôles
qui devront être opérés parce que cette
loi est une loi effectivement d'
équilibre qui va apporter une meilleure
justice notamment à celles et ceux qui
vont devenir avoir des taxis aujourd'hui
mais ça va nécessiter un contrôle
important et on a vu que les moyens
manquaient donc j'ai entendu que vous y
étiez attentive mais je crois qu'il va
vraiment falloir pousser les choses
encore plus loin donc pour ces raisons
là nous allons maintenir notre notre
abstention mais enrichie évidemment du
débat parlementaire qui a eu lieu je
vous remercie madame cohen dernière
intervenante madame escoffier
merci madame la présidente chez je
devrai tout à l'heure mon intervention
en parlant de funambulisme je voudrais y
ajouter le mot magique au magicien c'est
notre rapporteur dont je voudrais saluer
encore une fois comment à travers le
débat que nous avons eu dans la
commission de développement est ici en
séance nous avons pu parfaire un texte
dont vraiment nous avions au départ dit
que nous ne nous ne voterions pas notre
groupe
dans sa diversité habituel le votera
pour certains d'entre nous je serai
celle qui votera le texte dans tel que
nous venons de l'adopter et d'autres de
mes collègues resteront sur une
abstention parce que comme cela a été
dit très bien quand même par beaucoup
d'entre nous il reste des points qui
vont être d'une véritable sensibilité et
qui nécessiteront certainement plus tard
qu'ils soient revus et modifiés et
corrigé et enrichi mais je voudrais
vraiment saluer le travail qui a été
fait très constructif de nous tous
aujourd'hui merci je vous remercie
madame escoffier je vais donc mettre en
voix l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
relative aux taxis et aux voitures de
transport avec chauffeur qui est pour
voter le texte
merci qui est contre abstention
merci mes chers collègues la proposition
de loi relative aux taxis voitures
jusqu'au sport avec chauffeur est adopté
madame la ministre
oui madame la ministre vous avez la
parole
juste je tiens à remercier l'ensemble la
dessinatrice et des sénateurs qui sont
présents mais pour ce vote dont qui a
été donc acté à l'instant pour que ce
soit aussi bien les votes pour ou les
abstentions je tiens quand même à
remercier sur l'esprit constructif qui a
eu lieu durant ces dernières heures sur
un sujet difficile sur le sujet
passionnant puisqu'on arrive même en
touche et la tour eiffel pour moi là et
même la même voyez une midi pyrénées ne
se rend compte du symbole que c'est mais
je tiens vraiment à saluer votre volonté
de construire d'avancer dans un esprit
d'arriver à trouver une concorde
vraiment général et jeu en plus je salue
ce travail qui a été mené dans des
délais que je reconnais tout à fait
contre 1 et qui ont demandé un gros
travail à monsieur le rapporteur et un
effet je salue également ce sens
sa ténacité mais également sa grande
élégance merci à toutes et intime
mais seul à porter vous avez la parole
je remercie madame la ministre pour les
propos qu'il vient de tenir un temps moi
je suis je suis assez fier que nous
ayons travaillé sérieusement dans des
délais courts mais après tout nous
sommes là pour pour faire avancer les
projets les dossiers je pense que c'est
un bon texte je voulais remercier
les administratrices qui ont travaillé
avec moi puisque le poids du travail
reprenne et aussi sur eux c'est toute
une équipe le même la directrice de la
la commission aussi qui joue un rôle
tout à fait important voilà c'est un
texte qui est qui est votée qui qui va
repasser à l'assemblée je crois qu'il va
être utile dans les délais dans des
délais relativement
de moyen terme mais il va falloir le
faire vivre et sans doute aurons nous
l'occasion nos aînés qui viennent de
retravailler d'euros réévaluée mais
après tout c'est le rôle de législateur
je voulais vous en remercier et merci de
votre compréhension
merci monsieur le rapporteur